melani it's melanie but you can just mel mel okay i got you
she is playing lifeline and then what's left i don't know
other than we got watson and bloodhound yeah yeah okay i can
play bloodhound okay now i can do watson that's not okay
that important right as long as you're playing up all those
fences yeah yeah as long as i'm fence i'm fine i can do that
okay perfect All right, guys, we're here!
I muted myself.
I need fucking...
I need to... I'm gonna get a shortcut for muting.
I just... I learned on these tournaments, these guys just
talk to their chat.
They don't have actual...
What?
Does that mean to me to say...
A lot of these...
I need to get used to it because a lot of them, they talk to
their chat instead of talking to the team and I'm so not
used to that.
And then, brother, I think of the Akasua Bye.
Thank you.
All right.
Give me.
There was no intro because we were talking about strats.
So I had to, like, figure something.
I had to, like, let you guys in because we were talking
about strats.
I wasn't even the latest person.
Look at Team 11.
They're missing Team 11 and Team 9.
I'm not even the latest person.
How the fuck do you do shortcuts?
Oh, Keybinds.
What's a good button for Keybinds?
What's a good button For I don't even know what button to
use to mute people or like mute myself.
Oh my god, how do you do this?
I'm trying to where's the mute?
How do I fucking oh toggle mute control shift M.
Okay, we are not Doing that.
That's way too much.
Um What is what is a button that's not used too much?
Is it used for anything?
think i don't know what do i control shift okay we're just
gonna learn control shift m yeah bro my channel okay okay
i'm looking at the discord channel and our entire channel of
content concrete chat entire channel of people is all muted
nope nobody wants to talk to anybody
but everybody's muted bro oh my god everybody oh my god bro
i'm looking i look i'm not gonna dox obviously i'm not gonna
dox the fucking discord names but like it's like mute mute
mute mute mute mute like every other channel every channel
is like mute mute mute and then one guy's not muted and then
timmy's channel they're all actually talking to each other
oh my god timmy and naughty and the team eight seven and
five are actually talking to each other that's crazy i think
i took something up what's up what if we do what if we do
mel on bang joki you on you're still gonna be on watson
sweet and then i can play path okay and then i just did the
shortcut guys fucking shortcut yeah like i'm like kind of
thinking bloodhound might not even be that worth it yeah i
mean if you smoke and i'm in my alt i'm you i can't see yeah
so like what what what as the fourth though bang lifeline
path are these strats you castle if you're gonna go if
you're gonna get off bang you should just play like new
castle or lifeline so lifeline i don't know what i haven't
touched apex in a while guys oh yeah then it would then it
would then it would be you online i'm just gonna exist i'm
like i'm like how the mighty have fallen pathfinder might be
pretty goaded for this i thought there hasn't been like an
engaging fps games in so long and like four before is like
we're gonna know where people are you know like it's
literally it's like massive squads there's so many people
there's 15 teams and there's four people for each team okay
bring up the discord max out melanie and bring up brie okay
max out melanie bring up brie are you excited sound guy to
do sound check every two games i'm so excited all right
bringing it up right now all right here you go all right i
did it anyway so every two games every two games uh we are
we're going to uh swap team it's going to be randomized
teams um so by the way participated okay this is on me
participated in a lot of tempos tournaments but i haven't
got paid for one of them because i've yet to do the tax
forms for i was like telling tempo i was like wait have i
been paid yet tim was like didn't do the tax forms i've been
telling you to do the goddamn tax worms for months, Doki.
We can't pay you because you still haven't done the tax
forms.
I was like, oh, shit.
My bad.
But then, like, a couple of months later, I'd just be like,
hey, have I been paid yet?
And Deb was just like, please, we sent you the tax forms,
Doki.
So, anyway, I should do the tax forms soon.
I should do the tax forms for for it it's because okay no i
do my taxes but i can't receive the any of my tournament
winnings because from apex because i keep forgetting to do
the main tax for him to receive the tournament earnings i
can't get tax evasions if i don't receive the money like so
so i keep forgetting i keep forgetting to do him and because
of that i have yet to be paid I've been doing I've been
doing this for like free so far that's like at least like I
swear I think that's at least $10,000 that Tempo's been
holding on to for me oh my god I'm a mess Tempo's literally
holding 10k for me right now um Doki no I participated so
many tournaments guys it's okay eventually um toky please
fix your life guys step by step okay step by step guys we're
slowly very slowly fixing fixing step little by little um
you can make your own invitation oh with that hey at least
i'm not committing tax fraud I'm just not receiving the
money.
I have an accountant.
I just, the issue is that all I need to do is forward the
form.
Okay.
I'm making this more worse for me.
That is my only issue.
I just haven't forward the form to my accountant.
That, look, that's a lot of buttons to press, guys.
That's a lot of buttons to press, chat.
So it's not my fault.
It's just a lot.
It's a lot of buttons.
Please, we're worried.
Wanted to go down.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Speaking of engaging FPS games, Valve just banned like a
thousand of the cheaters and bots in TF2.
And the game's finally playable after years.
It's amazing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, but there's no actual competitive scene for TF2
anymore.
You didn't say that it used to, but there's not really much
of a competitive scene.
Um, I think like, I don't know.
know, I'm down to come back to Apex again in the future.
It's just that it feels like definitely, I was talking to
Ditto, and like we were like, you know, crying about the
lack of engaging FPS, like new FPS games and stuff.
Ditto was like, oh, you should play the finals again,
because apparently the finals got better.
But I feel like, yeah, it might be better, but I feel like
there's no competitive scene.
I just like games of a competitive scene because it just
makes it it just makes it much more like there's like a
worth to playing it i know there's like leaderboards there's
like top 500 for finals but you can't really flex it if you
tell somebody i'm top 500 in the finals they'll be like what
it's just look i need the ego boost i mean like what's the
point if i can't flex that shit you know what's the point if
i can be like i'm top 500 in something and then they'll be
like what like
esports seems to be dying general it's dying because a lot
of people a lot of boomers who know nothing about esports
are like funding a lot of money into the esports scene and
then now they're pulling out because they realized like wait
the investments were never worth it so because of that a lot
of the esport companies are dying now because they got a lot
of boomers that were like wow let me commit 10 billion
dollars to the overwatch league and buy a spot and like like
what was it there's like football teams like football owners
um that were like overwatch league is going to be the next
um nfl let me invest like 10 billion dollars into getting a
spot for Los Angeles and then sorry Los Angeles I don't know
and now they're like pulling out the investment and they're
now scared to invest in eSport because they're just like oh
wait maybe that wasn't a good idea now I'm never gonna
invest ever again because uh because of that one time when I
invested in this one thing and it wasn't worth it so that's
why like that's why eSport is dying It's not because of
like, oh, um, it's because like over the years, it's people
who are just like, no.
Also, like, my chat's dead and I don't know how to fix it.
I don't know.
Oh, there you go.
Never mind.
I fixed it.
JK, I knew how to fix it.
Um, um, it can be profitable.
You just can't like, you just have to like invest smartly
into things.
You can't just chuck a million dollars into something and
then just be, and then Also, there was never, there's no
like oversight.
That's, this is oversight esports, by the way.
This tournament is like run by oversight.
But there's no like, there's no, what's the word?
There's no like, anybody like actually like inspecting and
like monitoring where the money is going to.
And because like people would be like, I'm going to chuck 20
billion into TSM.
And I want you to rename your org name to FTX.
Sorry, it's not too soon.
He's in jail now.
And TSM, you can spend as much money as you want on anything
you want with that $20 billion.
And because of that, like, they fucked up because, because,
like, you know, they did monitor where the money was spent.
And then it was actually a scam in the end.
Yeah, I'm ready.
I got the comp.
Yeah.
I got the juice.
it yeah we're i got the juice oh i hope we're saying we're
saying everything the same but i'm gonna play newcastle
instead of path hey lifeline newcastle perp wait are they
like contesting for stuff like brie brie you're gonna play
you're gonna play yeah yeah yeah the fuck is watson oh there
she is guys
we have a problem i have to tab to my discord to mute my
discord we have a problem we're landing at rig and basin so
I'll just like tell you guys where to land when we drop I
don't think we're contested so we shouldn't have to fight
anyone yay that's great to know oh yeah I think we're good
oh my god it's Kings Canyon the smallest fucking map there's
two on this first yeah oh my god with four players per team
okay this is gonna be a massacre all right um mel you're
gonna land towards basen here drop us i'm gonna go basen
with mel and then someone land someone land here all right
and then and then someone land at the actual rig i'll land
here then okay yay
you want to go like far side of here
guys i'm this team doesn't talk oh my god oh my god oh let's
hope they don't require me to communicate
i don't remember how to socialize i don't it's okay i have
no input i have no input to give to these people at the
moment i literally just exist it's okay guys we will we will
tap back we will unmute how do you make friends again oh my
god I haven't done this in so long you guys leave x it's
gonna be pretty big for us I'm so shit I'm a mess I'm a
fucking mess right now I don't know how to communicate with
strangers I guys I used to be so good at this I don't know I
used to be so good with with strangers if you don't find one
okay actually i don't need that oh i don't know what to run
i don't even know what's good anymore oh yeah i grabbed that
eva harver there i've got a night assault spawn okay uh i
guess i'm heading over to for a havoc and also a hemlock
okay all right
hemlock oh all right guys i'm gonna i'm gonna try it i'm
gonna just gonna not run a pk i'm gonna
interact let's hope i don't get shot when i tab out mark you
stop and find a havoc are you supposed to head to you
dropped uh yeah you guys can just like loot towards me all
right cool you're gonna you're gonna you're gonna go hit
that Oh my god, that's so far.
Okay.
Heading over.
Yeah, you're good.
Joki, can you carry the ultimate XR?
Yeah, I can.
I have space.
Where is it?
I think I'll be getting it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Should I do the fast revive or the attack cooldown?
So I have my drone ult done.
Do fast revive.
What about me?
Do I get revive or falling?
You do the Arc Star one.
a drop mark there we go
oh okay what do you think end zone is gonna be uh this will
probably just end towards map room so oh my god that's so
far like yeah kind of rotate yeah hmm oh i think i'm
thinking i'm thinking we go towards i'm thinking we go
towards labs we want to get to purple so that way um we can
get brie her wait a team died or it how how did a team
already dies it was hell's team okay we're better than hell
no matter what we're better than hell that's crazy i'll
carry it if you don't have room oh there's a hemlock i see
all right we have four evacs all right that's good we should
should um look to get this eva harv and then hit this
assault bin and then we should all be perp off of those too
yeah yeah and then once we do that we can probably uh hit
the labs portal and like fly and take something all right
here's that we hear nothing right now we're here's shots on
the west i think they're fighting over there on the west oh
wait i see i see there's a bangalore alt Go get that assault
bin, Mel.
Are we going to fight them or are we just going to fly away?
It's only placement, so like...
Wait, what placement do you get money?
I don't remember.
Top six.
Yeah.
Top six?
Okay.
That's easy.
Yeah.
I see that.
Let's hit that assault bin.
We're going to go to labs after that.
Yeah.
Nice.
Thank you.
Let me go ahead and drop my job while we're over here.
Do I get split circuit or power pylon?
or two pylons?
Double HP, yeah.
Double HP on that.
Nice.
You are me, me, right?
Link.
Yeah, I mean you just keep it on Lifeline, yeah?
Yeah.
Alright, let's go hit the portal here.
I'm still holding that turbo for you.
Oh, okay, I can take it.
Oh, there's somebody in Map Room.
They stuck their territory there.
yeah all right let's go hit the portal oh where are we done
where are we planning on going anyway in the end we're gonna
fly towards hydrodome okay and then we're and then we're
gonna like look to probably try and like maybe get on a wall
here or something okay okay we're just we're just looking to
get into uh repulsor all right we ready take it wee oh
i'm looking like looks like the wall is going to be free i
think we land towards the left over here okay and like over
here and then i'm gonna evac all three of us up to the top
okay i i fucked up my fall i forgot a dolphin it's okay
let's hope nobody shoots the evac they are fighting in these
buildings in front of us it's all crypto really okay oh yeah
just heal on drone here actually almost here guys Yep,
you're good.
Hey.
I think we just take our close building here.
Okay.
Climbing up.
They might be on the other side.
I think they are.
Yeah, they are.
You see this lifeline?
Do they see us?
Yep.
They have blues.
That guy's dead.
Nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice.
She's trying to go tap.
Watch out behind.
Nope.
Can you put...
I'm dragging around.
Dragging around.
Here you go.
Oh, yeah.
I'm going to wash another door.
Can you...
That door's broken.
Can you put fences everywhere?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I forgot I was watching for a sec when you die.
I was like, oh, yeah.
Should we put pylon?
There's a sniper.
Was on that height.
Probably put it in the room.
yeah yeah i put it in here you're all good on bats uh i have
five bats yeah watch that sniper yeah that's getting shot
here i'll just just keep this door closed that way if you
get if you get shot or anything you can just come and heal
on this oh yeah whoa yeah melanie's jamboree yeah more fence
do i have a lot it's okay it's like a little puzzle Oh, I
have two more.
Uh...
Nice.
Oh, they have a fucking ramp on it.
It's okay.
Now we live here until we're top six.
We don't have to do anything.
Yeah, we're vibing.
Ooh!
Guys, I haven't touched this game in two weeks.
all right girl i just got my new pc no passion in they smoke
those i guys they might be training it's not my main team
yeah if they if they pull we just gotta fight out yeah can
you come can you come play out here with me no yeah just
like smoke right here and cross i think if we get i think if
we get pushed like we need to play on this side by the way
because we'll get sniped on from the other yeah we we gotta
make sure yeah if we get pushed don't ever like peek on the
west side because you'll get shot from the whole server oh
yeah yeah oh let's hope zone hands on us yeah i mean it
honestly if the zone oh what the hey there's somebody right
here be careful they might go to see you if you're in here
gotcha it's okay i don't need it i'm yelling on the drone by
the way should i drop my care pack in front of this other
door or in front of the front or this back door i think you
saw that like right here right here so we can have a little
bit more cover to like peek out
all right we're not safe can we um can we start moving this
way yeah can you guys come out can you smoke out here and
just yeah loot your pack smoke out here
wait which where are we are we using a redeploy or just yeah
we're gonna like we're gonna like run out to our north it'll
just come to me just come to me drop down we're gonna like
look to just get in zone honestly okay here let's let's go
right together all together i feel so safe running we're
just gonna we're just gonna get we're just gonna get in the
bunker here in front of us okay you guys ready to cross
maybe smoke right here mo cross here run they can't shoot
down okay just play here for now let's get like Okay.
I honestly want you guys to come all the way to me.
Come all the way to me.
Coming.
Come, come, come.
All right.
We're gonna play somewhere here.
I don't think nobody's in here.
Nobody's in there?
Fence this in.
Would you rather play that building?
Honestly, yeah.
Okay.
I'm gonna take my fences.
We can like just play kind of everything, you know?
Yeah, yeah.
We don't really want anyone to play near us.
Yeah, free.
All right.
Fencing.
Should I put my alt somewhere here?
or keep it yeah you can put it like maybe right in the
middle here all right just like right in the middle of those
two things there's stuff here okay okay i can't put it here
because there's stuff in front of us please somebody take
some of the things they pop the zip they probably yeah i
almost cracked this here they have purple they're getting
shot right now yeah this is the I might be able to nade one
here.
They're getting fried up there.
I killed one.
I'm putting a tower.
Nice.
Oh, nice kill.
They're looking down.
I wouldn't take that.
Yeah, too.
I didn't get hits.
Alright.
That's that one.
I'm back.
I almost killed one.
They're both low up there.
I'm gonna bang all down.
I think the bang died again.
If we get a bunch of ticks, I think we like...
I cracked them, shit on them, shit on them.
Oh, nice.
Can we take it?
I'm going with you.
One dead.
Kathy's.
I got another.
Kathy, Phil.
Plus the other teams.
I got a gold rose.
I thirsted.
Nice.
Hello.
I'm down here with you guys, so.
Okay, okay.
I can give you an E back here, it's been.
I'm going to loot this stuff.
He has bats.
I got six.
All right, this is looking like an Evac-in angle.
Yeah.
I think the tower and tower play for Rubik's Hiss, do you
think?
Do we reach it all over there?
No, we don't.
Nah, it's not really possible.
Honestly, I think our play is to go, like, there.
What do I do?
Yeah, like, you see this?
This is one guy.
You see that?
It's just one guy there.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think what we're going to do is two of us, at least
two of us, are going to pop Evac's.
Doki, we're going to pop you in Evac, so don't worry.
Oh, yeah.
We got to move soon.
I have an Evac, too.
Yeah, we do.
All right, here.
I'm going to pop it.
Pop your Evac up here, someone.
Maybe you can.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
You can't?
We're just going to take this one then.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
They're going for that ping right there, okay?
All right.
Don't dip at all.
Just fly straight to it.
I'm going to try and wall instantly, okay?
Okay.
I just got just land in there.
Landoki, and you're going to need a gen here.
It's only two guys.
I got hit for 100.
I'm already hit.
I'm hitting 100.
You got to tap me, tap me, tap me.
Fight, fight, fight.
It's only two guys.
Oh, I couldn't.
No!
Now we're getting shot in the ass.
Yeah, we got shot by everybody there.
That was so many people.
These guys are literally just holding everything, bro.
I know.
There's nowhere to move into.
Oh my god.
You tried them.
That sucks.
Yeah, the end zone was pretty fucked.
Yeah.
I literally got hit in the air for 100.
Yeah, I did see that.
That's ass.
your shield man that sucks okay we have a second game in kc
well yeah how does it work is it i think is it randomized
teams um it's every two games every map is a new team oh
really yeah oh every map is a new yeah every map is a new
team so like kc is a new team like kc we stake together and
then Because it's every two games.
And then on the second game, Temple's going to tell us who
our new teams are.
Okay, gotcha.
All right, it's okay.
We have round two.
We have round two of this team.
Now I need to look at fucking SoundGuy's notes on how to
adjust everybody.
Yes, there's like five frames because I'm tabbed out.
All right.
Melanie is quiet.
Yeah, she's so quiet right now.
It'll very be time to switch, though.
Well, honestly, I'm let her be quiet.
Okay, so sound guy does not like Melanie.
Okay.
Sound guy was just like, it's all right.
Because everybody else, everybody else sounds okay,
apparently.
It's just, don't say it like that.
all right um but everybody else sounds okay right sound guy
is just fuck melanie right if he was chappos like i want to
hear what melanie has to say like um but yeah sound guy is
everybody else okay though is every everybody else okay Are
we are we are we good to go with everybody else Wow sound
guy.
How could you I just met Melanie I can't and she's my new
apex.
Oh, she Yeah, okay drop I love as long as I guess as long as
dropped and free.
This sounds okay Yeah, if I look left and right you can see
it's it's not noticeable that noticeable because um i'm not
like as big on the screen but i mean i could just okay i'll
show you guys i'll show you guys okay actually no because i
i can't i don't have the i don't have the keyboard shortcut
to like reposition myself and i'm lazy so look zoom in on
you oh never mind apparently never mind i disabled my hockey
give me a sec guys let me fix this okay i need a be i need
to disappear for a sec because like i have my bindings to
like items that would put items out on my screen so that's
why it doesn't work give me a sec i disappear now so i have
to disable some stuff like i disabled my all right here you
go okay um i need to disable stuff and only put aim
If I turn it on, I would have...
So many things are going to start fucking going yaha.
A lot of things are just going to suddenly show up.
And we'll be so confused.
All right, there you go.
Hockey's a bitch.
All right.
I'm back in it.
So you see this?
Whoa.
So if I start aiming, it'll be like, zoom.
And then, okay, because I can now, I'll just show you guys.
You see that?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Left, right, left, right, whoa.
Left, right, left, right.
Whoa.
And then aim.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
So yes, that's how it works, guys.
So yeah, it's okay.
Now I won't, like, throw in, like, 20 different toggles in
while I'm playing.
So at least, like, now we know, like, nobody's contesting
us.
That's good to know.
I can see the code.
Guys, see, I told you, even though I have aimbot eyes, even
though I have aimbot eyes, it doesn't mean jack shit because
we didn't get, we didn't even get top six.
So it's, so it doesn't matter.
be like oh my god you have wall hacks like that didn't do
jack shit wall hacks not gonna save me from four different
people from 20 people shooting at me like
for like like 20 people were shooting at me you think wall
hacks can save me i'll just get to see those 20 people uh
surrounding me hmm i don't have the speed hacks that's why i
can't go i'm not sonic no one saucer one who's on his team
who's on his team and can he be on my team next game
all right which team are we better than where's us dropped
we're better we're better than half of oh wait he's not tsm
anymore we're been forgot he's not in tsm if at least we're
better than falcon better than falcon and tsa and half of
tsm my my my benchmark is that as long as i'm better than
hal in a tournament like for a game in a tournament like
that means i've made it that means like i'm not that bad
That's all that matters.
As long as you're better than Hal, plays higher than Hal in
any game, then you know, you know that you're not dog shit.
That's a win.
You play higher than the CEO of Apex Legends?
That's a fucking win.
Poor Hal.
He's, what is he gonna cry?
He's gonna cry for his millions of dollars of playing for
Saudi Arabia?
Like, let me go.
Oh, no.
Joki, you can't.
You can't say that.
Bro, he doesn't care.
He doesn't fucking care.
Bro, he has the oil money.
Like, what the fuck?
Does he do think he really cares about...
um we're getting an additional bro how much do you win how
much money do you win from this per game like two like okay
two thousand eight hundred split by four guys two thousand
eight hundred split by four guys um all right this next game
we're gonna hit 700 do you think he hears about 700 when he
has literally that way we can know where the game is like
gonna end you know okay yeah i'm down and then i'm gonna
play pathfinder so we can have uavs okay that way we can
like hit the third circle and then just basically like also
uav to see what spots are open and then just rotate in a lot
of people are playing valg also yeah but i mean we're
finding so many evacs i don't think we need valg i don't
think yeah i think valg is just for like if they none of
them have evacs type deal yeah yeah i should be bonish but
we had four evacs and three pois yeah we're gonna get plenty
of evacs i was thinking about playing back too but i think
everything else is just better so only you're changing the
character right yeah yeah we're keeping the same characters
other than me okay okay who said that well we know you don't
care now look i care i'm just lazy that's different i i have
a million things going eye that's different i care too i
don't know what i'm talking about i also care i just have a
million things i just do it right now now i'm not gonna now
i'm not gonna forward it just despite you
you a child you know they're like um now you know people
kids are like now now that mom wants me to do it i'm not
gonna do it i'm gonna hold that 10k hostage that's gonna be
like my rainy day fund the moment i'm like um the moment
like i'm like oh shit like i need 10k to pay off something
I'll do the tax for it I'm gonna I'm gonna make tempo Hold
on to Hold on to the money and have it build up More and
more and more Until Until I It's like interest rates Except
there's no interest rate going in Except
It's like He's holding it in just for the sake of holding it
in he's my bad tempo bank the tempo is gonna be my bank
account uh my emergency turn k whenever I need it um it's
not tax evasion if I don't do the forms that's how that's
it's not how am I fading taxes if I've never done the form
I'm just not fucking claiming the money yet I just haven't.
Okay, you know what's funny?
So you know how I did that Apex sponsor?
Tempo is also handling that too.
So like handling the payment for me.
So I still haven't.
I didn't.
So the tax form covers everything.
The tax form covers all of the Apex payment.
I did my other tax forms okay I I did the high tax forms I I
did so many okay I didn't my accountant did all the tax
forms okay all right okay tonight tonight after this after
this in between in between this stream and abcon stuff i
will forward my tax form over to my accountant and then i'll
finally i'll finally i'll finally do the taxes i'll finally
i'll finally claim the taxes not claim the taxes i'll
finally claim my prize money I think I think it's like at
least 10k including the sponsor I got like including the
apex sponsor money um I think it's 10k because I did so many
fucking um I did so many like tournaments for tempo so um
there's so many tax forms you don't understand there's so
many forms I can send so many I look at I don't have to do
any of them I just look at it and even then I'm like there's
so many forms and this is going to turn into the PC unboxing
stream again but Doug thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you this is different guys this is so different
oh my god it's not evading I just didn't never claim the
money if I never it's like I just it for free all right
round two yeah okay this game is a w yeah top six no we
gotta have low expectations so it'll be a little surprise
it's like a little birthday present okay okay i'm saying w
though if you want top six you're gonna want top six what do
you even get for top six oh yeah hundred dollars yeah
hundred each oh my god i can i can pay for my disney plus
subscription with that what the fuck how much is that disney
plus subscription i don't know it's fucking disney they
always need more money
i don't know what do i get do with my hundred dollars that
i'm gonna add to the temple one whole month
yes guys that's a hundred dollars to the tempo bank
yeah i mean honestly and i tried to tap whoever went down
after that too and i was like i'm just rusty on newcastle i
could have lived there if i would if i would have just cute
if i would have just thrown my cute my shield i could have
probably lived but i just i don't play that character really
you guys invest in the joki bank i keep my money in the
tempo bank
all right i need to head over to the center you hear doki
all right yeah i'm not unmuted no you went over here mel you
guys should do push the talk like loot like under the
balloon and stuff push to talk seems so much more convenient
now now that i think about it in these games oh my god why
did i do push to talk for quads i should have just been
doing push to talk all right push to talk guys it's been a
while guys i doing these tournaments i feel like i just i
like not i'm off my groove i'm off my group with like
socializing with new people it's just it's It's been... I
used all of it at Avcon.
No, they can't.
I muted myself.
That's why they're like, are you alive?
And I'm like, oh, I'm so muted.
I just wanted to talk to you guys.
Okay.
No, I won't forget.
I think I did.
Did I do push the talk before?
Guys, it's...
Bro, I don't remember.
It's been so long since I played with a randomized team.
oh my god they don't need to hear me i give no actual input
you guys ping evacs for each other if you see them yeah
gotcha like i my in my intel is literally useless to them
they don't need my intel like how am i gonna help my team
anyway i'm not gonna assist him in any way
Nice.
I mean, it's not like, okay, yes, I am an introvert.
It's just that, like, okay, also, there's four of us, which
means that's close.
Four of us equals getting hit by introvert dokey because
there's four of us now.
It's easier when there's three.
When it's three, it's so much easier.
gas like i think they really want that thousand dollars guys
or no 700 dollars like i feel like they really want that
seven like i can tell they're also like super these this is
a try hard squad these guys care these guys actually care uh
i got i got size i'm chilling yeah i need a all right i'm
gonna loot this and then oh my god ammo.
I'm gonna loot this and I'm gonna mute myself, guys.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna do it, guys.
I'm gonna hit this UAV.
Oh god, I didn't do the control.
I didn't do my job.
Hit your console when you can.
Oh my god, I knew I didn't do it.
I didn't do my job.
I'm so sorry.
Oh my god, here you go.
And then we're just gonna go towards this UAV next.
Alright.
Nice.
the tempo i want money to put in my tempo bank all right all
right guys this is the last thing i'll say i'll see you guys
on the other side before i try to talk to my team and
socialize going towards
oh oh my god we're so far from zone again no yeah yeah we're
good though um hit that assault bin
I need a hemlock if you'll find one.
All right.
Oh, I want that bat.
I still have...
I still have a white backpack, so if anybody finds a blue...
Can you smoke me on this beacon, Mel?
Just come up, like, climb up.
I'll wait for you.
Yeah, there is a team you guys that I'm going to go body
block.
Yay!
Yeah, there's a lot.
Hit this.
This is just kind of a hard zone to read, honestly.
Like, I want us to play for that, but it's going to be
pretty impossible to do that.
Yeah.
I mean, we have four Evacs again.
Yeah, I'm thinking, like, we can go for, like, this house,
maybe.
Are you aiming this Harvester, or no?
Yeah.
Hold up where?
Right here on top spot.
Yeah, I mean, yeah, you can like hold all that
I don't have it there was like there was like a bunch of
people like me Yeah, somebody there You can maybe shoot one
of these guys off of this last one Oh, nobody's getting on
taking it.
They're in front of us.
They're in front of us in the open here They know about us.
They know about us.
They have blues cracked one
down the hill.
Lobos cracked.
Lobos cracked flush.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Can you guys pull?
Shoot him.
Right here.
No, he's sliding down the hill.
Yeah, they altered.
They altered.
They did sliding.
Okay.
I'm getting a right angle.
Can someone look at our back as well?
I'm looking.
I lost our back.
Oh.
I'll look at them.
I'm just getting sentinel.
You're inside from across the way.
I'm good.
I'm looking behind us.
Nothing behind us yet.
I think they got the res up.
Can we just go through the choke?
Okay.
I just don't really know where the full kills are or
anything.
No.
Am I kidding?
I'm pretty sure they res did.
Probably.
Yeah.
Because they altered us off.
There's a team, there's a team here.
Chill, chill, chill, chill, chill, chill.
Chill, chill, chill.
Whoa!
Back up.
I'm gonna pop us as if, yeah.
Yes.
Okay.
Don't be dropped.
I'm good, I'm good.
Just back up, back up through zone here.
We're safe like right here on this corner.
Okay.
There's a lot of teams here.
We might want to just wrap around a cage.
We can still redeploy and we...
Yeah, but these guys might shoot us, so we should just run
off.
I'm done.
We can come around here and honestly play for these beacons.
Okay.
I need to drop my packs too for my gold.
There might be a team on this side because they came from...
There was.
Yeah, we can...
You can pop your pack here.
We have heal drone or no?
I think they're gone.
yeah they're gone come in the zone with me doki you're gonna
hit the you're gonna hit the console okay I get I'm gonna
hit the UAV yeah we can get drone when you get out doki you
can just pop ranges hey are we all stick up yeah their
meller dropped yeah I'll come back and get it I'm just gonna
hit these beacons real quick okay I'm just gonna syringe
before I take this Yep.
You're gonna be good.
It's only a zone one.
That's not that far.
Uh, yeah.
Yeah, this...
That's free.
Oh god, if I'm gonna make it.
You can just pop a wrench or something, pop a heal.
Yeah, I'm not gonna make it.
It'll be good.
All right Yeah, look at bunker by the way like bunkers free
we could literally just evac there couldn't we like from
this hill I think we can make it in the doorway.
Does anyone have extra syringes?
Because yeah, listen, come to us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah I don't I don't think it's really
that worth it.
You're gonna get shot from everyone just come to us.
We should go for a spot here I'm heading over I'm gonna wait
for Mel to pop a bat and everything
I got 12 seconds.
I just dropped it for her, Tori.
All right.
We're going for a bunker door, okay?
If bunker door is taken, we're going to swerve back.
It looks free, though.
I don't see any movement there.
If there's a team here, we just got to slam it, okay?
You need to smoke the door here.
There's a team here.
Play up, pop, pop, pop.
All right.
oh no I need to get up top they're setting up in there
though I might have to smoke for me again so I can get up
there oh god I think another team's walking up I live here
now oh there's kids up top looking at y'all need to get over
there y'all goodbye I know I know you're good if there's not
top doesn't see me I'll be I don't have an alt Excel so
yeah.
That's crazy.
Dropped died instead of us.
I literally said to land up here.
They might be swinging out on you.
I almost cracked.
I almost killed the bang.
You can't see anything.
Other teams are just going to look at me when I'm over here.
That's not good.
They're just looking at me over here though.
I'm gonna try to sit right here.
Hello.
I'm gonna...
Oh, you have an alt-excel.
Nice.
Uh.
One of us will live.
Yes.
This is another one.
One of us will lose.
Are you actually getting me?
My home.
No, they're gonna shoot at me.
Fuck off.
I don't know if this will help you.
Oh, hey.
They want me so bad.
Are you safe to sit here?
I don't think so, but where else are we gonna go?
Yeah, nowhere.
look at all these arc stars that they threw at us oh you get
them when they i did not know that oh god okay okay whoa
okay all right chill a little bit
okay that's all right your stick on that spot more probably
you were safe up there still yeah if you can do your gen
back you could definitely like maybe gen behind there yeah
yeah there might be enough space and then you guys can just
i'm 38 at the moment so it's gonna be a while maybe check
for altic cells on our box no i i used i took that altic
cell oh okay yeah yeah i would say i would say wait till
your next gen and then yeah just try to people up top are
gonna be sliding down on us yeah pop your yeah pop your
lifeline pack in front of you guys right there because if
you get a moby you could res us that's true try and get it
as close as you can to you Yeah, I know, that's what I'm
trying to do, but...
So, like, look up.
There's a rock above you.
I see them.
I see them on the other side of that smoke.
Okay.
Maybe move out a little bit now, Bree, and, like, go to the
right side, and not that way.
Behind them?
Yeah, yeah, right there.
Right there.
Perfect.
Yeah, it's perfect.
It should give you a mobi.
It gives you, it gives you, like, loot based on shit.
Oh, uh...
Other side?
No, that's so fucking stupid.
Whoa, was that your gold pack?
No, I already did my gold pack.
What RNG, you guys?
I just gave another gold.
There was a supply.
That's so weird, why?
That's scuffed as fuck.
Hey, it's okay.
We're not the team that died last.
75, guys.
The team died before us.
The team inside moved out.
I have no idea.
I'm just surviving.
I'm just worried about the team behind us at the top.
No, I hear people in there.
They didn't move out.
Just be careful.
Because this might be a different team that might know we're
here.
Yeah.
the single we left i mean i guess the only thing we do is
just hell mary redeploy we both have a redeploy behind us no
that wasn't that was a bunker that was a bunker they're
trying to kill you guys now go climb up please don't kill me
climbing up nope yep you're not gonna fucking have them
goodbye nice try guys holy shit there's so many people gonna
try to hit us oh my god it's okay not last second last all
right ggs ggs guys ggs all right oh my god they all just
left all alone in team two we're in the sense of camaraderie
they all just left Who's my next team?
I was...
Shit, I am with Saucer!
Guys, remember?
Saucer got first!
I was like, oh my god, give me Saucer so I can also get
first.
Oh my god, they hurt!
Before Saucer leaves us there, Deaths.
Can't all...
Guys, I don't know about you, but I died the last.
I did...
my job.
I guess I'll also leave.
Alright, let's figure out how to do push to talk.
I haven't done push to talk in a long time.
Push to talk.
Okay.
Fuck.
We'll do...
We'll do this.
Okay, mouse 3.
Yeah.
Alright.
Alright, we're pushed to talk now.
Everything's fine now.
We're pushed to talk now.
Alright, so our team, our second game, our second game our
second game sorry the second game would buy so fast our
third game is with uh zero loves given fey and then there's
me then there's me so we have saucer uh zero and fey um
temple bank is fixed bro um what if we like die so fast i
can't Our pro died first.
How?
Like, literally all we need is our pro player to be alive,
to do something to, like, help me.
No, not Falcon Zero.
Content creator, Falcon.
No, sorry.
Content creator Zero.
I have no idea who the Zero is, but this is Content creator
Zero.
Um, I mean, I live.
I lived I don't know As the weakest player I'm alive
I did it I did it And that was to survive Okay My job was
literally survive and I did it Um There was no way we were
gonna beat the bunker team Because the bunker literally was
ramparted up Oh my gosh.
This... This Bangalore is very confident.
Okay, there's a reason why he's very confident.
This has to be their pro player.
This has...
You know what?
Oh, it's Zainu.
Yeah, he deserves to be confident.
Yeah.
I was like...
I was like, damn.
This is some fucking confident pro right there.
There's a reason why.
It's like a roller brain right there.
haven't been playing Apex this much because like, um, I'm
just, I'm, I just don't want a 1v1 controller players.
I'm just tired.
It's like, it makes me wish I was adding my sis right now.
Yeah, Zionu from SSG, yeah.
Um.
Uh, yeah.
I think that, that's also why I haven't been playing a lot
of Apex.
Because like, I'm just tired.
1v1ing roller players.
Because it's just not as fun.
I think it's not as fun as one viewing an MNK player.
Because you get to live a little longer.
You get to live a little longer against MNK players.
So, like, you can see.
You can see if you'll die.
You know, you can, you can, like, think a little bit longer
um i think that's like like ditto's been playing finals too
because she said like in the finals no one uh people you
can't really play what the fuck is that movement goodbye
verholst um holy shit that movement was that verholst that
died i don't know but that movement was not gonna fucking
that super glide is not gonna save you from aim assist uh
poor guy Wait, that Bangalore literally got top five for
them.
He's gonna get $100.
Bro, he got $100.
He can also get Disney Plus subscription.
Go him.
Oh my god.
What the fuck am I?
Okay.
What is this game?
Oh my god.
Oh.
Okay.
what the he's just grieving he's really just grieving oh my
god oh my god he gets to watch that shitty star wars
adaptation guys no one's playing watson watson guys i don't
think guys i don't think apex was meant to be a 4v4 game
guys i think there's a reason why apex legends was Three was
the magic number.
They realized.
Three was the magic number for Apex Legends.
Bro, four is just too many.
Four is actually just too many.
Especially when it's like final zone.
You kind of like fours.
Yeah, but when you're like playing against a lot of really,
really good players.
teams of four it's uh it's a lie
oh oh shit it's okay we're not last as long as we're not
last that's all i care about too
um wait who's who's a wope all right that team okay all
right who's my next next map just with saucer zero fate and
and me all right let's see what number is this team nine are
you people in team nine or no okay the old his old team is
still in there guys his old team is still i don't want to
interrupt anybody his old team is still there um oh i have
to do team i need to change it too oh that's so annoying
all right let me fix this uh that's so annoying you gotta
like change the avatars and everything too all right i need
to i need to change it all right nobody's talking i don't
want to be the first one to talk really
someone say anything oh my god she breathed thank god hello
all right hello hello how are you guys schemes it's good we
came to six last game i was not last and that's all that
matters i got gas money didn't win money but i was not last
all right you'll win some this game i can't wait to win my
hundred dollars i think i'll make more just streaming right
now chat i'll make more i'm not gonna lie i think i think
i'll make more just getting super chats at the moment
where's team nine wait i can't even join team nine wait all
right so what are we playing wait you got first you you have
the game winning strat you know the meta
Saucer is not existing, okay, never mind.
Saucer's not here to help us.
Saucer's not here right now.
Would you like to see us leave a message after the beat?
Accra.
That's my bad.
All right.
All right, what's the con?
What's your chat?
She wins.
Lifeline good.
Pathfinder good.
I'll play a bang because I'm a one trick.
And then...
What's the fourth character?
Anything else?
You won first.
What was the comp for first?
It was Newcastle, Rampart, Lifeline, Bang.
But I think Pathy instead of Newcastle is good.
Okay.
You guys are okay if I take Pathy?
All right.
Yeah, I can not play him for the life of me.
So that is all you want.
Okay.
Wait, what was it?
It was a Newcastle, Bang, and what?
Lifeline, and...
Oh.
Well, we're going to do Path, Bang, Lifeline, Rampart,
probably.
Okay.
Actually, what map is this?
Lumpus?
Okay.
i can do lifeline all right all right can i go how much time
you think we got in team nine probably a good minute a
couple minutes probably okay so we're doing rampart not last
yeah hey turn down zero and bring up saucer all right turn
down zero bring up all right i brought give me a second i'm
gonna see if my dog poops i'll be right back okay all right
oh my push the talk is so much better nice yeah okay now
bring i'll just stand wherever ring console is if we get one
yep all right nice oh thank you guys thank you for the extra
thank you thank you thank you we don't have to give more
money to tempos bank account thank you guys to the super
chatsクby thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
yeah probably.
DJ, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Not last money.
Thank God.
Not last.
That's all that matters.
You're beat at hell.
Money.
Oh, thank God, guys.
Thank God.
We don't have to give more money to Tempo's Bank.
Guys, I can't even get into my own team.
because there's two team nine isn't moving let me in team
nine um i practically got six place via super chat money so
like bro i got oh my god the only day i got six place i got
two six places
oh my god somebody someone let me in team nine sad
please I'm gonna steal Verhals's team oh thank god that's
all you have to do just sad face team nine that's all you
have to fucking do sad face and then they'll be like good
I'm like that I'm sorry.
I feel bad.
All right.
We have, we have, we have four more games left.
So we have, I think, I don't know what our second, our third
map is.
What is our third map?
Our third map is Broken Moon.
All right.
Nice.
Broken Moon time.
I don't want to get back into the apex though I just feel
like it's definitely definitely feels a little I think the
content just feels a little dry at the moment it's more so
of like I think it's not more so of like the game gunplay at
the moment for apex it's who you're playing with and also
tournaments I think that's like basically at the moment I
think like apex is at a place right now where um it's who
you're playing rampart right it's yeah who you're playing
with and also tournaments uh i feel like regular apex and
new season launches if there's new content this is why i
didn't look into like the rank split like cool tech i
usually just like if you're ever in a bang all you could
just slam the walls down in a triangle they'll be safe or
like if there's a lot of nades i'm listening to my igl even
though it doesn't matter to me um i think like right now
i've only been uh um um i've only been paying attention to
uh gun like uh who we're playing with tournaments and just
new season stuff um i heard the new season getting me
exciting i'm not gonna spoil anything gonna make sure i
don't leak anything
so but i heard that the new season might be pretty
interesting.
So, um, can't wait to check out the new season.
Okay, I maxed out Saucer.
He's at 200 now.
He was at 160.
Um, I'm actually surprised Shibuya Hall, uh, decided to host
V Psychio for Apex again, because, um, you know, he said the
last V Psychio was the last one, but it's never the last
one, I guess.
um i'm gonna be surprised i thought maybe i think i honestly
thought the next vcyclo would be like a fighting game
centric one did i miss anything uh no no no we're just
waiting for the game to start oh no we're waiting for you
we're waiting for you you're stalling the game wait it was
me yeah you're literally the last person oh yeah but i there
we go honestly i won't be surprised if it was like con like
because they have shibuya has like merch so like actual
merch sold in japan and stuff like regarding me psychia gang
violence outside there what my neighbor's dog and my dog oh
okay i was like i thought you meant like actual gang
violence i mean people were shooting i'm in a way i was like
are you here that america yes oh well i do oh i came i came
outside in my uh there's a that had a corgi it was like a
black and white corgi and um wait i have a yorky and she's
very territorial and she's not like trained around dogs so
the lady came up to me and she was like is it okay i'm like
i'm gonna say no and she was like i don't know and then they
kind of like smelled each other's nose i was like oh and as
they're connecting this damn rock wall that comes out of
nowhere and wait where the fuck did the wrong party i don't
know he came out of nowhere and he started barking and
pulling his owner hard and my dog got scared and that lady's
dog got scared and the friendship kind of like separated and
i was like fuck this is the perfect connection it's okay did
you get her number no oh did you not get the old lady's
number no she'll understand the old lady's like you're not
into gills Do you understand?
Fuck.
No!
But you don't care.
You don't care about your dog.
You rather your dog be a loner forever.
She has two people.
People are dogs.
That's different.
She's about to get a companion.
I'm about to get a cat also.
Cats are not dogs.
He wants... They want dog friends.
What if your only friend was a dog?
I mean, isn't that how it is?
Like, man's best friend of the dog?
Yeah.
Right?
Man's best friend of the dog.
You're not even friends of your girlfriend?
Um, but we were talking about the dog.
Why we went backwards?
You said, what if I was the only friend to the dog?
It's like saying, like, would you just want one friend
that's not even a human?
I mean, personally, with issues that humans have, yes, I'd
be okay with having a dog as a friend.
So, like, not even the girl.
Like, you don't even want your girl.
girlfriend to be your friend i do i do but excluding her
because automatically she's my friend that's my girl so
she's my girlfriend yeah but your dog doesn't even have like
a girlfriend a dog like a girlfriend or a boyfriend well
because she doesn't want nobody to come around her you don't
know that what if she wants a boyfriend what if she wants a
boyfriend what if she wants babies she can't have it oh yeah
because you took away her choice i did it i did it I didn't.
I wasn't the one.
Make sure you take the UAV trade.
I got you.
The one for people or the one for circle?
People, people.
People, yeah.
That's the one I always got.
We are hydroponics in Elysium.
Stop.
He's already dead.
Go Elysium in with me, Zero, and then Faye and Doki.
You guys go Hydro.
All right.
Perfect.
Cool.
I'm down with it.
I'll land south side of you on west side of Lysium.
I just hope we're not contested.
I'm gonna land on this side.
You have a spy bin right here.
All right, yeah, I'll land on that far left then.
I feel attacked.
That was so good.
You're attacked!
You're poor dog!
That's crazy.
Wait, why am I jump faster?
Shit!
Okay, I didn't even realize.
Hey!
Sorry, I got so absorbed over the fucking dog conversation.
I didn't even realize I was jump faster.
After this, can you sound my forehead?
It's okay.
We already bonded.
This team doesn't care as much.
We running what we're looking for.
Snipers are good.
AR one trip.
Oh, man, I felt that.
Sorry for your loss.
Alright.
Oh my god, we're finally within zone.
Thank fucking God.
I feel like we didn't get zone.
I think another issue is we didn't get fucking zone.
It's okay, guys.
Bruh.
I'm gonna eat back.
Dad's also neutered.
There's a evac here.
I hate you.
nice little oasis though I like it oh shit are you gonna
take that you got that cash so yeah yeah yeah alright yeah I
took it like dad's choice too I saw you people call like man
skin a little weird shit I mean it's just a UAV to me I
heard that do we want cooldown or rapid response uh the
faster res whatever that one does all right there you guys
go so we got a team here and really nobody around us holy
it's okay he got muted when he was super young so he didn't
realize what he's lost uh there's a scent i'm gonna grab i
know like
He didn't know what she's lost if he got neutered as a
child.
All right, I'll just put a zip line there.
I'm gonna hold this turbo.
Wasn't there a havoc somewhere?
Okay, not child, child.
I did the recommended doctor suggestion.
The doctor suggested a recommended amount and I did that.
Do you want me to hit this UAV again?
Yes.
Gotcha.
All right.
There you go, Papito.
Medicima.
Let's start working our way into Oasis.
Wait, where's that?
Where's that senti?
There's a team coming.
Oh, yay.
I see that.
We're fine.
I see where you guys pinged the senti.
There is one over here.
Where are we supposed to go?
Towards Oasis, like on the left side.
What is it?
Over there.
Got it.
Oh, does anyone need bats?
I have six.
Whoa!
I need one.
I have three.
Run.
are you guys good yeah yeah we're good where you want to go
go keep going left side over here all right i'm a
refrigerator i don't want to get shot
all right guys i need to rebuy my push to talk my push to
talk is melee i don't know if you guys notice that every
time i'm midday i'm pushing the talk i also need shield
cells i couldn't find any uh i got up four right here all
right thank you Yeah.
Uh.
Like right next to the car coming.
Oh, we're good.
Are they right here?
Oh my god.
I poofed on them.
I have no science.
They're like boosted over there.
Can we evac once over here and go to Oasis?
Yeah, I'm dropping the evac.
All right.
Team flying to Oasis.
Yeah.
There's a team pushing that already.
Oh, that's not great.
Can we go?
I'm right there.
I'm right there on my ping.
You guys can make it.
I'm going to smoke off the left when we drop down under and
right and take the zip.
Okay.
Ah, bitch.
Just go right.
I'm the last person.
Wait, there's a guy under here.
One guy's alone.
You kill him.
I missed everything.
both sides make sure we don't get pushed
I'm gonna just lurk around and see if we could get any picks
Is that a sniper scope?
I'm coming right back
It is I'm bringing up a site for you guys if anybody needs
it Appreciate it What would you prefer Bruiser or 2-4
Alright Merry Christmas Thank you No problem Hey, a team
died already.
Not last.
Yay!
So, so, I think I know the circle.
I think it's the circle that's here.
On this wall, the circle that's, like, over here.
Okay.
Or it might be the circle that's, like, in this area.
Yeah, we can't really...
So, we can't really take those zips unless we get lucky in
3P a fight.
So, we're going to, like, play up into these stairs
eventually.
Perfect.
I'm, like, stuck.
Hi.
Oh, there's a team here.
I hear a lot of fighting Around us Yeah Seems getting fought
Like above us somewhere I'm looking to our left
Alright I'm gonna charge my sensei up See if I can get a
knucklehead in the head Guys I should not have made melee
push to talk Not really That was a very bad decision on my
end.
Oh, shit.
I'm going back down.
You're like right here.
Whoa.
I'm watching you.
I'm going to watch the bottom.
Good idea.
There's a false map.
I thought about it.
That's why I stopped so quick.
I'm scared.
Every time I push to talk, I melee and it pushes me forward.
Oh, my God.
I would have accidentally fought.
find that yeah they chose the wrong bindings you got a foot
pedal no what the fuck last time i played apex was two weeks
ago you should get one it's like two bucks on amazon oh i am
lagging really badly oh i have 50k of loss oh no how do you
how are you lying it's going down it's going down we're good
nice you got anybody in that house on the on internet are
you playing wi-fi no i'm hardwired my i mean my boyfriend is
overwatching but oh my god tell him to uninstall right now
exactly yeah like what the is he doing the hell that's not
even worth playing right now is he playing at least he's
playing rank right what's his rank that means he's not even
good if you don't even know his rank damn damn
If you knew his rank, you'd be proud of it, and you'd know.
Hey, drop me your...
I don't know what it is.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm going to respawn beacon here.
Even my girlfriend knows my rank.
I'm a bad girlfriend.
It's okay.
No, no, no, no.
You know what?
You can redeem yourself with this.
No, no, no, no.
It's okay.
You can redeem yourself with this.
What's his main?
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
You are a bad girlfriend.
Can we get a switch on teams, please?
Damn, it doesn't even know.
That poor guy.
That poor guy worked so hard.
He thought his girlfriend was proud of him, but she doesn't
even know he exists.
I'll make it a vault.
Should I anchor or come with you guys?
here for now okay they're like fighting above like on roof
yeah come to me come to me uh check come over yeah okay i
hear people behind me throwing a laser peeking over oh my
god no guys i don't think that was smart guys no maybe not
no Oh my god, there were so many teams.
Yeah, I think we should have held that.
I think we should have stayed, yeah.
Because we're going to circle now.
We would have been comfortable for, like, two more circles.
Oh my god, right.
Oh my god, we were!
Yeah, I was right about that circle.
It ends, like, it's going to end in that corner.
That top left corner, the top bottom corner.
I mean, placements matter more than kills.
Yeah.
when you get your hundred dollars it's okay i can i can
finally re-bind my stuff all right i'll be back all right
time to re-bind give me a sec guys all right instead of
melee i'm gonna put it on a different binding oh my god this
is how do people do this how do overrush play no sorry not
overrush how do apex players do this okay all right now it's
my weapon swap now it's better now it's not now I don't
whenever it's not when I'm meleeing
at least it's not I don't want to get a foot pedal foot
pedal you still have to bind it on something don't you the
foot pedal isn't like a whole new bind it's not a whole new
fucking bind though it's a weapon swap so like i oh wait
that could be worse you're right fuck what do people use
what control but like then i'll be crouching while i'm
talking like
caps lock wait you're so right i'm gonna do caps lock okay
all right i'm gonna rebind it on caps lock i'm so not
because i'm usually used to using mouse bindings.
Mouse bindings for it.
And, like, my mouse bindings are binded to stuff already.
So, that's why, like...
Because I used, like, Push to Talk for, like, mouse 3 or
mouse 4.
So, it's, like, I'm so not used to binding it outside of it.
Okay, caps lock.
All right.
Nothing can go wrong with caps lock, guys.
Nothing can go wrong with caps lock.
Look, our pro player through, we literally had, like, such a
free...
We were so free!
Wait, what the fuck?
We were actually so free!
He, like, told us to rotate!
Oh, my Discord crashed.
Oh, my gosh.
Looks like Discord has crashed.
Oh, shit.
Why did my Discord crash?
Wait, is Discord down?
for everybody no it's just me what the fuck is it just me to
everybody else's discord also crash or is it just me I can't
tell discord no I don't have PC discord no it's all right
thank God I hope everybody else discord crash do it it says
um it says like I can't reload desktop Discord at the
moment.
It just says, this is awkward.
It looks like Discord has crashed unexpectedly.
We've tracked the error and we'll get right to it.
Okay, let me try and reboot Discord.
It'll be better.
I'm binded it, but yeah, I can't.
What?
What the fuck?
Okay, that's weird.
All right.
Where's my task manager?
Do I not have task manager?
Oh, there it is.
Is that task manager?
Okay.
discord oh god okay i'm not using okay i'm gonna close how
do i oh my gosh i don't know how to use windows 11 i what
the okay and task okay all right time to reboot discord did
it work checking for updates Starting?
Did it work?
Yay!
Okay.
I did not leave the...
I did not rage quit my team.
My Discord crashed.
Alright.
Okay, I'm back.
Nice.
Alright.
It's okay.
They didn't even notice I was gone.
That's okay.
I don't know what caused it.
It just crashed?
i don't know i can't believe it it's not me saucer like
placed got first and also placed in those last two games and
now he makes a poor igl decision it's not me
that's all all i'm saying all i'm saying is that we should
have i stayed i ain't I made the right decision on staying
and then my we were in end zone no we could have lived there
we could have lived we made a mind-broke two people I had a
legitimate argument that's your dogs want more than dogs
want other dog friends like because only a dog would
understand another fellow dog like it is a legitimate
argument does yes dad has friends of course he does because
I'm not a monster
he actually does he every time we take him to the salon he
has he has his friends
yes he has friends other than me don't laugh while i'm
saying it i fixed yeah i fixed my keyboard um all i'm saying
is that i like my favorite part was like we're getting a cat
i'm like a cat's not a dog
So anyway, all I'm saying is that my argument is a
legitimate argument to have.
Like, dogs need to be socialized to have.
That's why some dogs are, like, extra aggressive.
Because, like, they don't, they've never socialized with
other dogs before.
So they don't know how to handle other dogs.
Because they don't never, uh, they've never, like, actually
encountered other fellow dogs.
So they're like, there's people, there's animals other than
myself.
see true I told you I knew I told you now you guys see my
side um a lot of dogs that tend to be like super hyper
aggressive tends to be like dogs that haven't been able to
socialize um when they are younger they just they've just
been like uh because like they don't know how to react with
other other canines too isn't that aggressive towards
children and old people?
Yes, because they're children.
Okay, no, I shouldn't.
That's not a good excuse.
Because dad sees a child and was like, I can take them.
No, no, no, keep going.
No, no, Doki, keep going.
Elaborate on what you mean by the their children okay dad
dad hates men kids and the elderly but he's fine with other
dogs okay he's he's fine with other dogs that's what the
conversation is about he's okay with other dogs
he just has a type exactly he just he has he has a type when
it comes to humans um that's no no that's not almost
everyone because he doesn't hate women he loves women yeah
women
Woo, women!
No, he actually likes all types of women.
Just not kids and the elderly.
Just not children.
Same, of course.
Yay, women!
He's just like me.
Look, he has a type, okay?
So, pick him.
What about when he hit a certain point of, old he doesn't
like them so like um it just depends on like how old how old
they are this is not all time win for women that is my
spirit animal
it's okay round two round two guys Sharko, thank you for the
super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Dad doesn't love hags.
Look, at a certain age, okay?
Okay, but like, what age is a hag?
Some of you guys will say 30 equals hag.
So like, like, I feel like, I feel like dad is like, okay,
like there's like a certain point.
I feel like 60, maybe the moment you look like you're old,
old, then dad's like, hmm.
okay because i know because like some of you guys are like
40 but yet like you categorize mint as a hag and like i
fucking hope to god she's not
and i i think i don't think mince 40 i don't think mince 40
Hag, hag, IRL versus hag, okay, what's, what's the age for
an online hag versus an IRL hag?
And like, so I was like, I hope she is 40.
Um, and, uh, okay, online high is 30.
Jesus
All right, if you remember the 90s, you're a hag.
What's the male equivalent of a hag, actually?
What's a male equivalent of a hag?
Because that's the female equivalent.
Orc?
Silver.
Gramps?
All right, how are we looking?
I don't think...
Oh, wait.
think we're pretty we're doing all right all right same comp
yep all right easer is that ojisan why does like why do you
guys why do you like why do you guys get the good ones it's
like ojisan and hag anybody else has a small dog or no easy
i have a small dog and He has friends.
Wow.
He just can't put it out there, huh?
Oh, a chicken shepherd.
Oh, hey, you got a guard dog.
I got a big girl.
Oh.
Yeah.
Does your dog have friends?
Well, does your dog know your boyfriend's ring?
Oh, that's...
I mean, she's technically his dog, so I would assume.
Oh, she definitely knows that.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Oh, wait.
It's not even your dog.
damn because like you know you know if you if you saw that
dog as yours you wouldn't say my boyfriend's doc you'd be
like our dog you wouldn't like specifically name that the
dog is not even yours like he brought her with him you know
it's crazy i don't mean to like you know chime on this but
that's my girlfriend's dog and i said it's my dog yeah see
he claimed the dog as his as well it's an our thing not a
his thing i call her my dogs sometimes like i say his dog
that shouldn't even be a thought in your head damn i feel
bad hey at least i give her the treats he doesn't whoa whoa
and yet you don't even accept it as yours
they hate her for she spoke the truth so did you did you ask
your boyfriend what his rank is no oh my god you didn't even
like check after we called you out you're not even
embarrassed that you don't know and you didn't even try to
fix it what's the bottom rank of uh what's the bottom rank
what have you dropped to the bottom rank yeah what if he
needs you to come for him right now.
What if he's crying right now?
What if the boys are making fun of him?
Yeah.
What if, like, they're watching the stream right now and
they're like, oh my god, your girlfriend doesn't even know
your ring.
Right.
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I got this.
He's just sitting there taking it all in like, I don't even
want to do this no more.
Yeah.
He's just, maybe he stopped playing Overwatch and you didn't
even know.
Right.
What rank are you?
Yeah.
he's gold too oh my no wonder you don't want to know his
ring
damn damn you shouldn't even have told us that you should
even told us his ring if he's gold one I like how through
all of this sorcerer has just bro he's not even gold one and
gold two because he doesn't want to get roasted he's scared
yeah i can't wait for the pathy recolor heirloom oh my god
stop he's already dead it'd be nice to have like all gold
boxing gloves ducky was gonna improve this hey we're having
good time we're laughing that's all that matters we're all
having a good time all right guys i need to let it all out i
was i was i was silenced earlier so now i'm letting it all
out isn't g7 worth it this year or no uh yeah it's pretty
good they like buffed it
Oh, hey.
A blue flatline.
I didn't know that was possible.
Whoa.
Oh, my God.
Purple.
So good.
Okay.
Not that I'm beating your vent wall.
I need to let it out.
I let out the aggression.
Microaggression.
I'm the type of person you call HR for.
let's see are you winning i'm not last that's a win in my
book bro if i find another evac i swear okay let me find
more shield cells i need that site let's see pts evac there
i swear i'm just i'm just being trolled that's it that's
that's what i'm understanding i'm gonna go get the evo let's
see i'm gonna make sure i have everything i need to open
this for loot all right i like what i got is chat broken
again i don't know what's going on it broke again i gotta go
to when you go to phase driver for the main console yeah
yeah wait is it when did it break actually i don't know this
circle if i'm not mistaken it's the one that's like oh it's
all the overlays broken too all right i'll fix that later i
don't really have time to fix it at the moment it seems
already leaving phase i believe we could just evac over all
right i'm gonna grab this bat and then i need i feel like i
need more energy ammo they're hitting the um button uh page
i've yeah i'm gonna drop an evac right here are we all going
there's another evac here in the house here's two evacs i'll
grab that yeah i'm so far but i'm going i don't know where
to go where do we go uh face driver face driver okay mirror
mirror mirror mirror
you want to go backside yeah oh since discord crash oh
discord crash the wait the discord crash the chat as well.
We'll just scan UAV and ring console here and then keep
going.
Yep.
I don't want to run.
I need energy ammo if you guys see any.
Inside the building.
Alright.
Scanning.
We're doing okay.
I'm gonna say that.
I'm gonna get fucking shit out of me.
Do you still need energy?
Uh, yeah.
I only have some VA.
Nice.
Am I kind of good now?
Have I gone to it?
stacks right here oh so let's get this ring console it
sounds like kind of on this
oh i'm scared i got this evo cache on the right so i got a
sniper digi and i can see there's a pk in here oh there's a
people over here yeah there's people over there bang i'm big
ball on this bang is going for care package wait i can see
in the hello no you can't they nerfed see her i can clearly
see her in this yeah i could still see her in the smoke yeah
what the hell are you telling us killer i've tried to but
she's jimmy quickens out here
where are you going are we just chilling here for now we're
chilling here just hold out hold out like our space over
here don't want to just bang drop just make sure no one
comes in like the west side like put these entrances i'm
looking yeah i'm looking this i'm looking this direction
there's nobody there all right that was an accidental thing
all right guys i'm doing somebody sniped them in the head
i'm doing uh recon i'm gonna make sure nobody's behind us
i'm being a good reconist guys there's nobody here look at
that i should do that with cover yeah they're
Oh, I see them.
I see them.
Is there anyone?
Oh.
I'm gonna wrap a little bit left.
Yeah, they're dropping left.
They're right here.
One's in smoke, two are in smoke.
Oh, shit.
I'm up on the bullet in the left over here.
Yeah.
I made a shot in the back there.
Uh, do I come to you guys?
I don't see that team.
I guess I do.
They're last team, but we're here.
I'm going a little bit back into circle.
Someone hold this.
I'll be.
I'm dropping an evac for it.
Oh.
Alright.
They're still over here.
They're still alive.
They're behind that big ass wall.
I can't see you.
Hey.
Oh.
Who's shooting at me?
It's not good.
realize I have four shield cells.
Oh.
I see them.
55 on bang.
Hi.
Playing ring console.
Putting down my package.
It's the non-care package package.
Non-care package package.
Like it.
Oh, bad.
So we're getting shot at.
Somebody's hiding right here.
Another person over here.
I'm playing left over here.
There's a blue helmet for you.
One of you guys has a white helmet.
Got it.
All right, so I have the 50% zip line.
Let me know where you want me to put it.
I saved it for now.
All right.
This one's going to be kind of rough for us.
There's a redeployer over there.
Sad though.
Oh, take it.
Do you walk up with me, Fave?
We can maybe hit ring console again.
I'm pretty sure that was the same.
I'm looking to our right just in case to our east.
Yeah, that team is just still on that building.
Long been.
Oh, never mind.
Maybe just chill.
Crack them.
I'll resmoke you any foothills.
Yeah, yeah.
You guys are good.
I have a Phoenix in the care package if you want it later.
I don't have any vision on anybody.
Whoa!
Oh, pulled far.
Should we just hail Mary as some Evacs?
Can everyone come north with me here?
Yeah, give me a second.
Yeah.
Fuck, Sean, not the UAV, we could have hit.
That sucks.
I'm going all around.
Oh, shit.
I fucked up.
There's a...
Whoa, there's a people here!
That bonsai team!
Over here, team!
Oh my god, I'm dead!
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got a guy coming.
They're pushing me as in?
They're pushing, uh, Doki.
Yeah.
Don't see him.
I saw contact.
Did you kill him?
They're running over here.
I don't know where they went.
I just got shot and I just got scared.
Let's just go north.
They kind of stole our rotate this one.
Oh my I don't know.
I just got scared and I inked.
What?
I put out my heal drone.
I was so scared.
Also scared.
She said I got scared and I inked.
I was so scared.
I was defense mechanism.
Try to walk through the terminal and get to my yellow ping,
like the buildings are there.
If we can.
Team right here.
Wait.
Okay.
That's way too far.
They don't know.
Shoot on the bank.
Okay, keep walking.
Keep walking deep if we can.
I don't know why the shields are here, but.
Yo, I'm lagging.
I'm lagging too.
Yeah, I'm standing.
Yeah, no, the server is dog shit.
Whole team, whole team, let's show, show, show, show.
Come back, come back.
Oh, God.
Oh, no.
Come back to where we...
Yeah, come back to the entrance we came from.
Okay.
Good luck.
We're fine.
All right, we're just gonna evac here into the compound.
All right.
Wait, somebody died to a ring.
What a nerd.
Damn.
I'm gonna tell him you said that.
we gone yellow ping compound I hope it's free but I have no
info so if it's taken to swerve but it looks good to me it
does not look good there's lifeline talking about oh yeah
this team yeah that line over here on left side over here
start setting up walls over here on me I'm being on thing
that team to get your pressure off of you so I'll res I'll
res or you res pass one pass one Nate again rest her again
fine fine fine fine there's so many there's so many whoa
nades nades more nades more nades dude yeah that's a fuse
team four nades i just needed my walls up i'm begging this
so many nades so many fused oh my god dude they're here
they're here they're here oh my god you're the only one left
just hide
did you hide oh my god he's still alive oh my god why were
there so many needs
There's so many!
You clutch this res all day?
Oh my god!
That'll be crazy if you get this res.
There's a bingo behind us, we can maybe 3p that.
Okay.
Oh my god, he's doing it!
Where do we go?
I don't see anything.
I see smokes, but I don't know if they're really fighting.
I don't know, but we need to find a safe spot.
Oh, I'm stuttering.
I don't have walls.
There's a shield right here.
Maybe we need to fight this yeah they're fighting they're
fighting we need to commit this watch right where you're
right behind mine's last mine okay I see that okay come to
me put chill the scene is getting third 3p I'm lagging so
bad no the whole scene running down to 3p it I can't move
holy fuck the server's dying show right here set up walls
what the fuck I can't move How is anybody shooting?
I'm trying to get involved.
Full team dead, full team dead.
Their second team is still alive.
I'm backing up, I'm backing up, backing up.
Okay, never mind.
Bro, I still see people in the fucking smoke.
What the fuck is going on?
The server is back to normal.
Fucking 80 years later.
I got red shields.
I'm chilling.
We're getting smoked.
We're good.
I don't see anything.
I'm fucking legally blind.
There's a whole team like pinned behind this.
We have to watch the scene.
Hey, they're walking.
They're walking.
I'm gonna move on.
Do you have Q?
Yeah.
He dropped her drone.
I have no shields.
I need some fucking loot.
This team is moving.
They're moving to that team.
They're moving to this team.
They're fighting.
This team's all right.
They're pushing in front of us.
Lifeline is late.
Zones are gonna start closing.
Get the kills.
Crack.
I don't know who I cracked though.
Lifeline, you cracked Lifeline.
Oh, I don't see them now.
They're moving up to you guys.
They're moving to us.
Just hold them out.
Close, close, close on the war.
Close on this like fucking face-to-life.
They're pushing, they're pushing out.
They're pushing out.
Flash one, flash one, flash one.
Look at this.
Look at your left, look at your left.
Kill thing.
I died, I died here.
Reloading.
Oh, that's gonna kill me.
That's gonna kill me.
She's behind you, she's in the ring.
She's gonna die.
No, it's gonna kill me anyway.
What does that?
Oh, there's a guy, there's a guy in the loot box.
Behind you.
Okay, full dead, full dead.
I'm dead.
That's a lot of people looking at me.
Oh my god.
One guy was hiding in the bin while I got being ulted.
Yeah, these zone pulls are kind of crazy.
this team gets to just chill here it's not fair I didn't
even see the path he he was literally like I got stunned by
the bangal and then like and then like I couldn't I couldn't
see him it was like blur oh my god that was that was
actually a crazy zone yeah the bangal fucking stunned me so
I couldn't see the the yeah he blended into uh into the bin
itself also we're poor as hell we were so poor we had
nothing this is not fair did you just sit here
he gets to sit they get to just sit here and not worry about
the war outside Oh yeah, I gotta fix my Fugie in chat Give
me a sec Oh Thanks for reminding guys See and then They
should fix it I'm pretty sure They should start bouncing
soon And I'll fix my chat too
And then Here you go You guys are fixed Alright, but not
that type of fixed Uh
Not like that You guys are back Where is I?
No
Alright I'll be right back when we use the bathroom I'll be
right back guys
Let's relocate here
Let's displace here
All right, I'm back.
Does this mean...
Dad hates almost...
No!
You guys can...
You guys can fix him.
You know how you're like...
I can fix her.
You guys can be like...
I can fix dad.
You're like...
I can fix him.
I'll be the exception.
Unless you're...
Unless you're a lady goon.
Then don't worry.
You already got the free pass.
Dad already loves...
was you.
At least, never last, though.
How did I think about it?
How the hell were we going to get in a good rotation?
We weren't.
That was the funny part.
It was just survive.
just to that that's it which we didn't do very well i mean
that rose was crazy though we placed higher we didn't get
any money but we placed higher
oh my god that poor team jesus christ that poor team fucking
high ground shit this team has fucking high ground Oh my god
That poor Poor fucking team Gigi's a drop
Dropped one The fuck How couldn't he How can he Why can't he
survive when he played with boss?
He died first The last two games I had of him And he lives
here Yeah
Drop couldn't do this earlier!
But it was my end game!
Drop!
Where the fuck is my end game?
Oh my god.
GG's though.
GG's.
It was fun playing with you all.
Yeah, it was fun playing with you guys.
GG's.
Nice meeting you guys.
Hey.
So on to the next team.
all right saucer gets to stay here because he's the fucking
pro player all right next team we have yuris a priest uh
yujin and doki that's me i'm doki hey we played with yuris
before we played with him before okay yuris is team three
all right i'm just gonna shimmy over to here shimmy over
here how do i how do i get over there i don't know how to
get over there how do i how do you shimmy yourself to
unassigned leave team oh my god i figured it out guys okay
we need somebody on your team yeah we played with pre's
pre's before we talked about we talked about we talked about
milf island i remember a pre's we talked about milf milf
manner was it milf manner the one with the fucking moms do
you guys remember that that conversation we had about that
reality show where like all the moms and their like sons
were trapped on an island and the sons were dating each
other's moms and like a priest watched it
and he watched it and then i was having discussion with him
about it because all i saw was the trailer i didn't think
someone was actually gonna watch it and he watched it so i
was like oh it's coming back to me now i remember it oh yes
yes it's a real reality tv show where like the moms like
were were you know with other the their son oh my gosh it
was It was a, I don't, it's, I didn't realize somebody would
actually do that show.
That, that show was wild.
That was a wild show.
That's for sure.
It was definitely wild.
Wait, there's a season two of the dad?
There's no way.
Wait, I need to look it up now.
I'll join a voice chat later.
No, the season two, Milk Manor, there's only like one,
there's two, three, there is a season two.
Wait, is it actually?
Barbie is a former stripper who currently works as a
marketing executive.
No, no, season two is still mom's, guys.
No, it is!
There's dads now!
They added dads!
Oh my god!
They added Anthony, son, a jo- They added dads!
They added dads who brought their sons.
Oh, my God.
They brought their sons.
Can't believe they added dads.
Change.
You're good, right?
It's about to change.
I'm so freaking cooked this tourney, bro.
I got overstimulated the last two games.
I started, like, starting, like, breaking down and shutting
up.
Oh, shit.
You're good.
All right.
Let's see.
Hello.
Hello, hello.
You're vibing.
All right.
Let's see.
What's up, Doki?
Long time too!
Hey, kid!
Now we're playing Enne instead of JP.
True.
The tables have turned.
Oh my god, Apriz.
I've talked to you before.
I don't know if you...
Yeah, fuck you.
He's just ignoring you.
Oh, he's ignoring us?
Bro, what a bitch.
I was messing up your back.
Oh my god.
And you didn't even say back.
You didn't even say back.
Welcome back.
I just came back.
Riz, you remember the last conversation we had.
The last time we got in a team together?
Yeah.
You remember what we talked about?
Because I was telling my chat, because I remember what we
talked about.
Because you watched Moat Manor, right?
Oh, that's not me.
Yeah.
Oh, now you remember!
Do you know they made a season two?
Yeah, well, do you need today, huge.
Fucking dads.
Yeah, they had dads.
Literally.
fucking dads they had a dad yo huge how you been today bro
so is it filth manner now no no they added so like instead
of just instead of moms and their sons they brought in dads
and their sons so the moms can pick either a dad or a son to
bang so the whole family's there yeah the whole family's
there in the end they're all getting moms in the end wow
yeah yeah guys yeah yeah i totally know what you guys are
talking about i feel so yeah man it's american reality tv
show uh yeah yeah like american american i'm out of that
conversation what do you what do you guys want to play um i
don't mind us talking about uh rampart is actually really
good so whoever can play rampart shall take rampart um
rampart bang who do you play who's who are you comfortable
with lifeline okay okay all right lifeline we have lifeline
what about you i don't know what what's meant what works in
quads in quads it's um What worked really well was rampart
and bang.
All right, I feel like you're gonna play.
I spaced out, I'm gonna be completely honest.
Okay, we're not gonna win, I think.
No, no, no.
If you need a rampart, like if no one's playing rampart, I
can play rampart.
Yeah, you're a rampart.
And then, well, you're east, why are you playing then?
I can play bang.
Then what the fuck, what's the fourth player?
What am I?
I'm thinking.
I was gonna rampart and bang, then what's the third?
We have either a beacon, like a path or a blood or a seer.
Who can you want to play?
I don't think I've seen anybody play Bloodhound during this
entire.
Hey, we got third last time with the blood.
Oh, yeah, third last time with blood?
Not first, though.
Yeah, that's fucking true.
That's true.
Okay, yeah, well, I can do blood.
I'll do blood.
We'll see how it goes.
What about path?
Wait, what?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
What about path and I play path and you play bang?
bang okay so we yeah so we have no okay all right he's
cooking he's cooking we're cooking we're cooking we're
cooking yeah yeah yeah yeah all right bring your grease down
a little bit all right and then we're doing path bang bang
rampart and lifeline yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay wait
so what do you mean by god oversimulated last two games what
happened yeah what happened Oh, I mean they're just talking
normally and like started getting really I don't know.
I don't know what went wrong.
I just stopped thinking like and I stopped talking.
What team were you on?
It was um, I mean, no, they're all like nice people.
It was Isai- Nah, nah, nah, nah.
No, who was it?
Who was it?
No, no, no, no, it was literally Isai new entity and rainy
day.
Oh, it was Zai-new, of course.
I don't know who he is, but of course.
Judging from his name.
Game unexpected.
I know he's a role-player too, so it makes sense.
And he's a controller.
And he's, wait, we're all M and K, right?
Oh, shit.
It's over, it's over.
Okay, well, BG.
Oh, shit.
Maybe it was the testosterone, you know.
It's over.
Gigi, guys.
I have a controller, though.
No, but right now.
But, no, no, you have a controller and there's a reason why
you stuck with M and K after that.
Oh, shit.
Oh, you've played it.
But didn't reject win?
Did you win?
That is true.
Did we win this?
I'm saying a reject right now.
Yeah.
Yeah, we are.
That is exactly what she's saying, surprise.
That is exactly what she's saying.
I was so brought down.
Yeah, one of you guys is Sanjin and the other.
Wait, who's the coach?
Who's the four?
Yeah, who's the coach?
We have no coach.
We're so it's over.
We don't even have a coach.
GG.
Oh my god, it's so over.
Oh, we're...
Guys, wait, where are we landing?
Do we even have a spot?
Darius, where are we landing?
Yes, yes, Dragos, Dragos, Dragos.
Don't worry, don't worry.
What if we get contested, Yuri's?
No, they won't contest us.
They don't know that.
They probably do.
They probably know.
Because they're like, I didn't die in one second.
They're M and K.
They see you.
They see you wall bounce and then like whiff and they're
like, oh, M and K.
Yeah, they see us walk and it's not in a straight line and
it's going to be like M and K.
That guy's strafing.
That is M and K.
Oh my god.
And if it somehow turns into world's edge, we have...
No.
We have Broken Moon.
We have... Well, I heard they improved Broken Moon, so...
yeah it's actually it's actually not bad yeah it's better
than fucking stuffing all of us in king's canyon that that
was scary king's canyon there's too many people in king's
canyon oh two more games two more games chat and then dry
gulch and then we it's off to work i know where that is i
mean i'm i mean top left pretty much okay okay okay and then
if it's uh world's edge no we're doing broken moon what yeah
if it's something apparently it bugs to world's edge
sometimes yeah yeah oh are we playing through if it bugs to
world's edge yeah oh we are okay all right nice i hope it
does world's edge better
I can't Some of the other maps love.
I can't believe you remember how long ago Do we talk about
that?
Look that was like my only thing Cause like none of us
because like nobody watched Milt Manor except for you.
That's why I remembered it because like we were just talking
about the trailer and you're like I watched the entire
season of Milt Manor and then that like that like left an
impression on me.
Wait Milt Manor?
Yeah, that's what it's called.
Oh, I thought it was mishearing shit.
Yeah, yeah, you can Google it.
Oh, yeah.
It's fucking lit, bro.
It's fucking lit.
Did you watch season two?
No, I haven't gotten that far.
Was season one good enough to watch through the entire
thing?
It was good enough for him.
Yeah, like, but were you watching it more like for the
lulls?
It's just so dumb.
There's like a guy in there.
There's a guy in there that's just like fully chat.
He's like, what's up, bro?
Hot single moms dive into a unique dating experience.
Oh my god.
Yeah, and he watched the entire season!
But aren't you also the guy who awowifies everything?
Wait, what?
Is that not you?
No, it's not me.
I see your titles and it's like...
Oh my god, he's rewriting history.
Okay, so the thing is, he's willing to own up to Milk
Matter, but he's not willing to own up to Owo.
It's a command.
It's a command that my mom's made and then they They made it
my, they like, ooh, my titles.
Yeah.
Okay.
It's my mods.
It's the mods.
Blaming the mods.
They do it for free.
I heard the viewers reflect the streamer.
Yeah, that's true.
That's true.
You cultivate your chat.
That's crazy.
Your mods do it for free and you're blaming them.
Oh, God.
Yeah.
Look at that.
I pay them an experience.
you're going to be the references they're going to call you
up as a reference yeah i'll give them a good like a i'll
vouch and you vouch people have actually used like
moderators to to apply for jobs i think oh you guys hear
that months you can use us as references because it shows
leadership qualities and not not me i'll give you a bad
reference what the hell oh god she wants you to stay you're
here for yeah i don't want you guys to leave so you're not
allowed to make gatekeeping my mod they're my mods they're
not gonna improve their job
that is true there is a lot of there is a lot of um
management going on in the chat so it's a very chaotic place
you can like exaggerate how would you exaggerate like
managing chat yeah what would you put down there your your
boss is gonna be like what's what's a twitch stream yeah um
actually like i actually volunteer in a community of um a
lot of people we're doing kc no wait what about wild age you
lied to no no no what is your case you thought uh we got
runoff in bunker town oh okay i turned down hurries and
turned up appraising more that's on your marriage oh thank
you you finally i know you like proposed but like you
finally married was quite a long time ago it's kind of like
the same time yeah but i never i never said anything no
you're good in in like a call so i just wanted to
congratulate yeah appreciate it thank you little love yeah
you're like younger than me and already married that's not
making me feel damn you gotta make it all about you yeah i
make everything about me i'm sorry i was like a little kid
that was yeah you were like 18 yeah i don't even remember
how young i was because it didn't matter you were just a
baby yeah oh my god rank days yeah and i think like i know
you got engaged i didn't know yeah yeah i didn't know he got
i didn't know like finalized married married what's going on
here yeah what is going on here i don't know i have no clue
it's bugged Please, we still have two more games.
This has more delays than scrims, please.
Yeah, we got two games to win.
Have any guys won your game yet?
Hell no.
No.
Listen, I...
Haven't you guys got last place?
No.
I got last place.
Oh.
I got 20th birthday.
Damn.
Listen, you just...
Listen, I watched the VOD.
That was entirely Greek's fault.
That was right.
that was entirely greek's fault was it really greek's fault
it was really greek's fault you had to watch that i need to
watch it oh we're getting you no getting a new lobby uh oh
wait let me pick my character so i don't fucking oh it's
true oh yeah space out lean custom match earlier well i kind
of thought like in retrospect that i also like you know i
landed like right side i was like And then I, like, waddle
up as caustic.
And then I start shooting a prowler.
But I didn't realize it.
I was going to shoot my prowler instead of my RE45.
So my aim goes on skeefy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
So then I was like, oh, gosh.
It's me.
It's my fault.
Oh, you close out.
All right.
Greek knew what he was suiting.
I'm getting like a scoop.
They're saying Greek did 19 damage.
Damn.
Yeah.
19 damage just snitching on his dumbass bro damn yeah to be
fair that game i did 54 damage yeah yeah you know as long as
you're not the lowest that's all that matters that's better
than him he used to be a pro yeah he used to be a pro player
he's a character so i turned down your ace again
oh my end sorry i believe in this team as long as we get a
house we can sit all the way to six place and do nothing
that's all we need look we gotta aim for higher come on look
we gotta i'd even get to at least six place i need i got one
six our top rating was seven i think my tower it was like
eight or nine oh my but i killed a person okay okay we have
yuris enterprise who plays a lot of rank and a lot of scrims
so you guys should know end zone you guys should know where
the house is the ideal house i have not touched comp in
about we both haven't we both haven't touched
rank end zone is that's all that matters can we bring a
coach in licole yeah can we can we bring a coach in can i
like facetime wig and just show him oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
call wig right now yes do it do it call him right now get
your phone down call him put him on the mic what do it all
right all right he won't be able to hear you though it's
fine if we want to
now all right let's see if he answers if he doesn't answer
he's not a real friend
if he doesn't answer your call i'll call him and see if he
answers my because i have his phone number too i'm not gonna
answer oh my god he's not he's actually not this fake fuck
he actually doesn't answer you oh my god you try you try nah
nah you do it if he answers that's crazy that's crazy if he
answers oh my god wait okay okay i'm gonna i'm gonna call
i'm gonna see you to try okay okay let's see i need okay i
need to find his number oh he's calling me oh Hello?
Yeah, you're live on stream.
Yeah, we don't know zones.
Can I FaceTime you and just show you the zone?
Doki?
Doki was asking us that we better know zone, but we don't
know shit.
We need a coach.
Yeah, we need a coach.
Coach us.
Oh, is it Doki?
Yeah, I got Doki bird.
Oh, yeah.
Y 'all are fucked.
Oh, fuck.
No, I didn't do it.
Oh, shit.
He did 14 damage?
Oh, damn.
That's fucked up.
Tempo do better.
That's a lie.
Tempo do better than me.
Just say it straight up.
Straight up, bros, you're a chock.
Okay, but it's not because of me.
It's not me.
Love you.
By the way, do you think my toilet is still, a grease toilet
is still stained for your Panda Express?
I didn't stain it I'm like What is happening right now?
No bro, that's all him, not me Alright, yeah, yeah, bye bye
Bro, he didn't even say Love you, you said love you Oh he
did, okay, I'm gonna say it, I'll be fucked up If he didn't
say it back He said I stained Greek's toilet Did you?
I don't think so Oh my god, that is not a no, that is not a
no That's not a no, that's not a no I mean, I might have
What the fuck did you eat?
Because I ate Panda Express from the airport Oh, like at the
airport Yeah, I was hungry Oh my god Yo, you brought a paid
Greek I got a pay to use this toilet That's crazy That's
crazy That's crazy that Wigg said that though He said he
instantly said his GGs Yeah Yeah.
Every game you did 14 damage.
That is not true.
No trust.
No, I was watching the Challenger Circuit.
They did well.
Yeah, we did so well.
You guys went to day two.
Yeah, we went.
Yeah.
And you almost got to day three.
Yeah, we almost made it to the finals.
Wink was supposed to sign us up for the next Challenger
Circuit, but he forgot.
Of course he didn't.
so yeah i've what is going on what's taking so long are we
not yeah i think the servers are broken or have you guys
been lagging by the way yeah i know the servers are fine
yeah mine is said you're on dallas but uh yeah no it's like
the lowest ping of like 90 it like fucks up um in the middle
of the game too that's the thing like like everybody's ping
just yeah packet loss and ping in the middle of fights,
which was crazy.
Yeah, someone told me I won clip to me and then I was like,
oh, but was it like did I like only win because of ping
spike and then I had to look back on the bot.
So was it because of ping or was it?
No, he went.
Oh, there we go.
Damn, you should play one.
That's your moment.
That's your moment right there.
He bleeds.
Yeah, I mean I was he's not perfect being but honestly it
was about time I got revenge because he shits on me every
fucking attorney or like content creator like match or
whatever I just get bullied and beat around and that was my
one that's why you gotta put yourself as like when they sign
up we'd be like what's your highest rank yeah put like plaid
or something so you get to be have like the lowest
expectations
yeah but most of the times i already feel like i am the
weakest link in most lobbies it's okay i'm here now no no no
literally didn't you didn't you recently get like top 500 in
overwatch no that wasn't that was in like season one in
overwatch two there's there's it's season 10 in overwatch
two now it seems like you can do it again you're like a
you're like a fbs like god the last time i played apex with
two weeks ago oh god damn oh god we might be cookery should
we just tea bag if we see a team and no they're just gonna
shoot us these guys really want that 700 this money involved
yeah there's money i literally made more via super chats on
my youtube stream than i if i Damn!
Damn!
You said you broke bucks?
No!
I'm saying, even if I win, if I win zero prize money, if I
win zero prize money here, my dragoons got me.
So it feels like I'm winning.
They're donating prize money to me.
Okay.
participation like a reward you know yeah okay so like i
told him my told my chat this but tempo is actually holding
at least 10k worth of prize money for me because i forgot to
fill in the tax form oh my god because i participated so
many of tempo's tournaments so like i never filled the tax
forms to receive it oh you got a game Go.
Let's go.
You guys know who you're playing, right?
Yeah, Bangalore.
Yeah.
I'm Rampart.
Yeah, you're on Rampart duty.
Yeah, I guess.
You guys got me, right?
Dragons, even if I don't win prize money.
Where's that?
I think it was from, like, end of seasons event last season.
Because we can't keep giving more money to temples bank.
I hate money.
It's me, a spendy, a whale.
We don't look very intimidating.
Don't say that, man.
What do you mean?
All our skins?
They don't look scary at all.
I have a pink skin.
That's so scary.
Faker does not use skin.
Yeah, but he has a $500 skin.
Where's our $500 skin?
Wait, we were too fast at it.
I don't know where we're going.
Oh!
What happened?
What?
What bugged out?
What happened, bro?
Yes.
After ten years.
Oh my god.
It's been so long.
He screams.
oh my god why why didn't we start i had bacon
question mark
all right i can't believe we don't even have a coach to tell
us where end game is yeah thank you bin thank you guys for
getting me even if we don't get any prize money or just afk
wait who crashed somebody crashed someone on drop team
crashed but now timmy's team is like spamming their fourth
because i think they're afk oh she's back oh okay wait more
than one person crashed bam jesus oh no yes finally oh my
god you're finally here again i already have red bars yeah
no i'm good my pc is okay
oh my god we're finally here it's okay we bonded as a team
guys see i knew i can get back into groove guys i told you
It just took a while to yell at me for anything.
Don't yell at me, though.
Like, I'm trying my best, but I might be a bit slow, so.
It's all good.
Bro, love yourself.
It is true.
Love yourself.
Oh, okay, I'll try.
I don't love you, bro.
Bro, you know, before this turny, I wasn't feeling the
bestest.
Oh, my God.
And now I'm feeling a lot worse.
Who hurt you?
Uh, you know.
I don't think we should trauma dumb.
I think we should lock it.
Oh, shit.
I think we have space port, too.
Yeah, I'm going to ask that.
Okay.
I'll go there.
He's just let me for real.
For real.
Oh my god.
If we have it.
Okay.
Maybe.
I can't do anything, right?
So I just land.
I don't got no bins.
Where do I land?
Oh, you got a bin there.
Yeah?
Oh, wait.
Yeah.
I think you got it.
It's Doki.
Nevermind.
Yeah.
Doki, you land on this side.
You're in the huge land on that side.
Okay.
I got you guys.
All right.
here it all began when i was born okay there's an evac tower
here nice we need those we need those yeah try to think of
what guns to put oh we need a long i mean we have we have a
uh rampage but i rather not use a rampage Oh.
Damn.
Oh, give me actually...
Oh, there we go.
Nice.
Carbine.
We're good.
We're cooking.
Oh.
Another Evac Tower?
Nice.
Do you have the cheese?
Any cheesers?
Cheese to meet you?
Cheese?
Cheese what?
Harvester, Evo Harvester.
Oh, any harvester?
I don't think I've ever heard somebody call it that.
Like, what the fuck?
What the heck?
I swear that's how they call it.
I'm dropping a bit of energy.
No, they just call it Evo.
Mac here.
Like, I got my sources wrong.
Where your source?
Maybe, do they call that in Japanese?
Nah.
What did they call it in Japanese?
In Nene?
They actually do say Evo.
Oh, Evo, yeah.
Maybe I got my sources from Japan too.
Yeah, true, true.
We don't have any that is...
Sad.
They're asking us to play on a hard mode.
Hard mode?
What's hard mode?
You know, no Evo, M and K.
Oh!
True, true.
We need every help.
We need more money.
Temple hates one of us.
or all of us, and that's why she put all of us on a team
together.
Where's the other one?
Can you open one of those bins?
I'll be able to scan the book and open it.
Yeah, I'm heading over there now.
We don't even have a zone beacon.
They're not even trying to hide it.
Oh my god.
Why don't you grab that 3x?
What the fuck?
there we there i don't know if they're close i'm just trying
to heal i'm going over to your east right now i left yeah
he's dead if he stays all right we somehow have a zone that
we don't know about jesus not even in core okay we someone
to call wig again someone we need them Am I there?
Yeah, careful.
Oh my god.
Wait, where did you shot?
Yeah, go towards, go towards the...
Hold on, I have the who.
Yeah, I'll watch for you, I'll watch for you.
Oh my god, we're white armor, please.
Be gentle.
Shots in core.
So we're going for the cheese?
Yes, the Eva.
The left side?
I'll go, I'll go take it alone.
Start looking into core.
Maybe set up this building.
okay there's an extra bat in here i'm chilling i have four
i'm gonna take it i think i think he needs it the most i
have i just used a lot i i have one are they still chasing
no right no they're not chasing they're not chasing oh we
are chilling you want me oh i think we have the zone close
you want me to get tactical or alt cooldown uh tactical all
right it depends i always ask for being because it depends
on the pro player.
Put down my ulti for some men.
Wait, we're here, we're close.
Oh, close.
What the fuck?
Wait, let's fight this, fight this, fight this.
On me, on me.
He's on the roof, I think.
I'm a shallow roof.
I heard someone close.
Oh, there's one on you?
Yeah.
Here, right here, here.
It's a rampart.
Wait.
I can't.
The angles are just too weird.
Yeah, I could and I got shot on the side.
63.
Oh, nice shot.
I think we have zone.
Wait, they zipped over here.
Wait, wait, wait.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
There's one right here.
I see that.
The whole team.
Yeah, yeah.
They're playing the...
They're running.
They're a Valkyne.
There's so many people.
We're gonna Valk all this team.
Yeah, should they should this.
Oh.
I'm kidding!
That was...
No flesh.
I'm gonna die.
I think the zone is somehow going fucking where we came
from.
I think it was on us.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure.
That sucks.
Let's go through this tunnel.
And we can control this height right here.
We could have stayed in the house!
We could have.
We could have stayed out of the house!
Temple literally gave us a house.
It happens.
I have four bats if anyone needs.
Yeah, I need one.
Okay.
Pretty sure there's, yeah, there's spots here.
Yeah, there's some good spots to our left.
There's, like, a really deep rock you can play in.
Yeah, we just play here for now.
Okay.
There's a lot of wall.
Is that someone else?
No, there's a team here.
No, no, there's someone else.
We did not go up here, Yuri.
It's, like, a good spot.
Up here?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
What the heck?
Oh, what is this zone?
No.
Wait, yeah.
even go like right here wait kind of cool yo this is we're
vibing yeah oh not not not that far left all right yeah yeah
they could peek this right here though that kind of sucks uh
there's a team in bridge you can even go like you can even
go more up here oh apartment whoa okay we gotta make
presents here though oh yeah people might just roll up here
because we're hiding there i'm gonna put this water on the
left because they could peek you right here urese okay oh my
god we can put four walls five it's six oh five looks like
people are here
i knocked oh my god damn thursday him wait we might be able
to get that thursday right here oh he's like deep in that
yeah the most i can do is just hit their watch and jen yeah
all good I really should know that was in gen whose boss.
Make them waste their alt-exams.
I'm mature.
I have 140 heavy.
This would have been our house right there.
254.
Dude, it was in our building.
I'm so sad.
Yeah, it was in our building right there.
It really was.
This is the second time I've gotten zone with no zone
knowledge.
It's so annoying.
i mean i feel like i feel like that was a sign when we had
team literally mock seven you over there true it is kind of
a hard to hold like over there that's true you could take
like a second floor but yeah i feel like cat would have been
better if we wanted to hold like a room over there yeah but
it's okay maybe zone will flip on us maybe we'll see the
zone yeah maybe we'll be lucky Yeah, we can't be that
unlucky, right?
Yeah, no, no.
The 4MNK team?
Yeah.
With no beacons?
What?
How did I break my wall?
Did you break your own wall?
There's a guy right here that I can barely see.
I feel like we need a new wall.
There's a guy right here.
He's really kidding.
Got a minute.
Can we somehow Eva?
Okay.
from there and you're back from here hey mode of my truth
yeah never mind in a minute a minute i thought i did rest
we're in the slow side
oh it'll be so funny if i hit a shot well i mean there's a m
and k noob are you like oh that guy's red armor the team on
the what the team has red that's kind of crazy bro where did
he get red is this hell
oh no it started not the fuse oh no the only thing that can
hurt us nades someone on a bridge yeah see in the next zone
close if we have to do anything
Oh my god.
These guys are just standing still.
Is it farming or what?
Like Trev right now.
Oh shit.
On stop.
Oh we're still kind of in.
Oh wait.
No this is not.
I don't know if there's still someone over here.
You can put like walls over here on the low ground.
You should be able to play that.
Because this bridge team can really peek towards us.
on this low ground yeah and you're in on my life then 106
dead i killed one here oh nice thirsty or just not yeah we
can't really rest now oh i'm just gonna stay with you yeah
that's just
i'm wasting my shield cells just healing on this next zone
close we're just gonna play the low ground okay okay we got
neil wait for pre's we have walls why we have walls we can
probably play like the low ground of the bridge too later
like over here defensively my package for mids uh yeah yeah
i don't think we're gonna get low ground yeah i played like
right here team balko thing and where they're going all
right what is that spot the team on the spot i gotta get it
for you whoa don't shoot me what do you need we're just
vibing in batting here oh i got three bats about five cells
but i'm spamming my sentinel thank you i'm just vibing
i'm here the whole team here yeah i'm scared i'm scared
should we start setting up yeah yeah my fault all right
let's see i like this i like this This is scary.
Yeah.
Yeah, there's still a team this way.
That team should get pinched, like this team playing this.
I think they're just playing the building and then that
platform over there.
Okay.
We could even play the low ground of this later too.
Alright.
Team playing this.
I don't see anybody.
They're all just very far.
Oh.
Yeah, I think we're gonna play the low ground of this
bridge.
That was our house.
What the fuck?
Oh, I can drone.
Oh, no.
All right.
Why are they not shooting that team in the bridge?
Maybe they have a secret.
That guy shot me at the gap.
I was like not expecting.
Wait, he just.
Oh, what the?
88.
Let's see if I can.
Try coming down in.
Yeah.
Oh, no.
Hopping.
I have the bat.
Putting drone on you too.
Yeah.
I can't see you.
I just can't.
I can't see either.
They need me.
They're needing me.
We're good.
Oh, I'm dead again.
I was trying to shoot them.
No audio.
Nice.
That was cool.
Oh, no.
I win these.
Oh, and teeth.
That was cool.
I didn't think they were going to push us.
That was really fucking cool.
Actually, no audio.
Oh, where did it come from?
Yeah.
Yep.
No way.
Oh my god.
Wait, where the fuck was the Watson team on the left
platform?
What?
I don't know.
I guess we just left.
I didn't know it was one team.
I didn't either.
We would have just played like...
Yeah.
We could have moved out so much.
I don't know where that team on the left went.
Yeah, I was so surprised.
It came up nowhere.
It was.
100%.
Nope.
They didn't fight.
Well, yeah, we have another we have another game just no
audio.
Yeah, that was just that's not on us.
That's not m and k That's on audio that was crazy.
I actually have never I was Guys at least not last guys He's
not last true true they had the freeze rotate what the fuck?
I don't know where everyone went on this side.
How did they get the yeah, I don't know they they I don't
know where they went up i hope they die that could have been
our house right there i hope they die me too i hope they i
hope they die seventh so they never peak down yes peak down
no why are you not peaking down die seven die seven come on
kill them come on make it seem like they're gonna get placed
placement money apex oh my god where did that team on the
left go do we not get our house we got audio it's so hard
yeah and everybody rotated away what the fuck they get such
a free rotate
okay but maybe we just get all our bad luck out of the way
and get a win yeah and then next game we have a comeback I
agree with that.
How come when you say that, you sound so depressed as if you
don't believe?
It's hard to like believe in that plan.
I can't help the depression that leaks into my voice.
That's just my state of being.
Oh my god!
Is this why you're playing it?
You still blame me?
Yeah.
Oh, that's why I've been taking a break for me.
Yesterday was like my first time in a couple weeks, but...
Oh, damn.
That's too real.
That's too real, man.
Oh my god, they might die seventh!
That's all I wanted!
Yes!
The lifeline of being lived!
No, no, no, no!
Yes!
Die seventh!
No!
Yes!
We got seven.
Wait, no, no, no.
What is happening?
That's seven.
How are they resing?
What the fuck is happening?
What the fuck?
Why are they getting such free reses?
They didn't res like 10 times.
Yeah.
This lifeline is actually carrying the frick out of them.
Wait, that lifeline just went crazy.
Yeah, their lifeline clutch did.
Yeah, gold knock.
Just tapping repeatedly.
Where's our gold knock?
Okay, I was 958 EVO off.
No, we actually got fucked up hard.
I'm not going to lie.
We had the zone.
We had no beacon.
No beacon.
Like, we got no audio.
You get placement money.
It's okay.
These nades.
These nades might be it.
Somebody, please throw more nades into them.
What is that?
Take them out.
What's the team doing, bro?
Just kill this team.
Kill the lifeline.
How is the lifeline not dying?
Yeah.
Just kill them.
giving her a job she's playing back wait how somebody please
fire the lifeline that lifeline's actually going crazy yeah
they're actually getting saved by the lifeline i can't
believe it this team this team is the main character we're
just the side characters not fair why can't we have be the
main character bro wait yes yes oh no wait they have plot
armor bro no this team's the main character it's not fair
what is this this is actually not fair the fact that all
four of them are still alive after all that too bro this
tournament is their stream not our stream so i feel like
naughty has been going kind of crazy these games Yeah, no,
he has.
It's okay, guys.
He deserves the money more than me.
I have you guys.
I don't need...
He has eight kills.
It's okay.
We don't need the prize money.
It was just gonna go to tempo anyway.
He's going for the kill leader.
Oh, yeah, the kill leader bonus.
Are you guys close to the kill leader bonus?
Oh, no.
What the heck?
Hell no.
It's okay, guys.
Prize money was going to go to the tempo pink anyway.
We don't need it.
Ooh.
How are they not their top three?
Someone at least...
Bro, that lifeline is about to run at someone again.
She's alive.
And she tapped.
Oh, my God.
How are they living?
kill one of them bring one of them down oh my god oh my god
oh my god she died finally yes god it went jesus christ oh
my god wait the rampart no he's killing the rampart oh my
god the rampart's living for free oh my god what wait how
did she just do that with a three x did the rampart win i
was pretty crazy no no no thank god okay she got second
though yeah fuck the moment Blind Idaho is all over for this
team.
Some crazy hating right there.
Yeah.
The more we hate, the more they succeed.
Fuck, man.
We need to increase our hate game.
No, the more we hate, the better they do.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Because we're just not on the level of Kendrick Lamar yet.
You know?
We're not depressed enough to...
To vent out.
Wait a minute.
I'll sweat and...
oh my god okay lg guys come on guys it's lg we gotta at
least get top six guys i want that last game was unfortunate
i would like some boba money i don't know but y'all kind of
fucking boba are you ordering damn a hundred dollars for
boba a hundred dollars for boba you could get at least are
you living in la don't dox yourself oh you oh my condolences
Okay, I live in like 30 to 45 minutes away from LA.
Oh, okay.
So it's not straight up LA, LA.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's better.
It's better.
And you don't have to pay like, you know, $100 for boba.
Yeah, only 50.
I can get like 10 bobas with toppings.
Maybe like.
What's your boba?
You know, what's your order?
Yeah, what is your boba order?
the last time i got boba i tried this like watermelon
coconut milk thing from yifong tea oh what yeah it was that
was fancy it was like a featured seasonal menu and i got
that and i didn't like it and i was i was like mad at myself
i was like why would i do that to myself that is actually
like the the boba experience whenever you try the fancy one
the plain ones are the classics there's a reason why they're
the classics true yeah you put too much stuff in it the
flavor just get too mixed up there's too many contrasting
textures it's not boba but it was um matcha and peach
somehow it was good no that sounds good yeah that sounds
good it was it was actually Hey, what's your boba order,
Priz?
I'm a basic bitch.
I feel like milk tea, like our brown sugar or Thai tea.
Isn't Thai tea like more sweet, right?
Yeah, I feel like you have a bit of a sweet tea.
Just for drinks.
That's it.
I don't eat like any snacks or whatever.
Like, do you have at least boba in your boba tea?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I get the balls You know what now?
I get the balls You get extra balls You get extra balls?
That's too many balls That's too much for me I can't take
all that What if I eat?
Wait, what's your ball limit?
You think I just count them?
I don't know The average Then how do you know when too many
balls is too many If you don't have a limit?
Oh, you could have I never thought about that I don't know I
just asked for the... That is a very good point Yeah, I just
asked for the balls I don't see how many Do you ask for it
like that though?
Or do you say like pearls Give me the balls?
Yeah, I was like, some balls please Oh my god I don't know,
what are the normal ones called?
Just tapioca, boba Yeah, pearls They started adding, like,
the crazy ones.
There's popping bobas.
Those are advanced.
Yeah.
Only the advanced boba drinkers can deal the popping ones.
The advanced.
You gotta level up before you can take on the poppers.
I'm not that advanced.
Popping boba with, like, a fruit tea is good, though.
True.
I feel like that is a good combo.
There's also the tiny ones.
The tiny balls.
Oh
You mix the big and the you mix the big and the tiny ones
together and the texture is really nice.
Yeah, no you should try the texture I need to try that next
time.
Yeah Big and small balls I get the big and small Hey, you
got the small balls oh and then there's like the there's
like the jelly too there's like the jelly too there's jelly
and there's pudding as well i've had the jelly jelly's good
yeah there's like different flavors for jelly i like the
leechy jelly oh the leechy jelly's good oh my gosh now i
want to order boba tea i want to order me some la boba tea
yeah i think if we win you can yeah i can You can have LA
boba shipped out to you at your hundred dollars.
That's true.
And then I'll just arrive like a singular cup at your
doorstep.
Guys, please, guys, I need that hundred dollars.
I'm not going to get my boba tea.
Wait, you never said what you get.
Oh, what I get.
I'm also simple.
I like the green milk tea and also...
um and also like mango uh green milk tea is really nice i
love mango green milk yeah i don't like regular like milk
tea i rather i like the green milk tea ones it just has more
flavor
uh guys what who what happened to naughty's team oh what's
happening this is a team yeah that's what i'm like yeah it's
their life no no no that no they just yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay oh my god wait they're actually started it oh no
oh my god guys maybe we maybe we cursed your irl wait she
yeah yeah it didn't work in game We actually...
We actually...
Oh, no.
Her internet crashed.
Guys, we're not liable for this.
We all have alibis.
Oh, no.
Her internet crashed.
That's so sad.
Are we bad people?
Oh, fuck you.
No.
No, I never pretended to be a good person.
Fuck.
Oh, no.
No, it's okay.
She's back.
She's back now.
No.
Oh, that's so good for her.
I like to see.
That's what we like to see.
Fuck.
It's okay.
That means like if she crashed now, that means she can crash
again.
Oh, true.
So like, there's hope for us.
All right.
The scene views.
Long ass fucking tournament.
It is.
Now we can die.
I feel like we spent more time in the lobby.
But it just means that we have a more time to strategize.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Talk about fucking milk.
I was going to say hate, but more time to hate on others.
But realistically speaking, what else have we done to
strategize outside of our control?
I don't think anyone.
No, we know what Boba to order.
I don't know.
IGF?
What were you supposed to do?
I was just listening to your guys' this boba conversation.
You know, I had a fun time.
I know what to order now, you know?
Yeah, but how are you going to order boba team?
We don't win anything.
We don't have some money.
I got a third last game.
That's you problem.
All right.
You died first.
I got bobas for one week.
For a week.
Damn.
I'm fed for a week.
Okay.
But like, what about the rest of us?
Oh, I'm sorry.
saying is doki call us broke yeah yeah you don't have to
worry about doki yeah she said you broke okay you're
projecting you're projecting oh my god beacons yay i wish
i'm that broke um you should land there doki on your thing
okay yeah yeah oh my god we got everything i know I'll land
here.
Yeah, yeah, I'm gonna land here.
Can I do a double scan?
No.
And then you're just gonna get a gold res and she's gonna be
her.
She's gonna be her.
I don't think...
Can you get a gold knockoff drop?
I know you can, like, a bin.
Yeah, you can.
You're gonna be her, I believe.
Can you go into the orange you got?
Okay, I'll try.
I'll land on a little pill there.
Yeah, I just wanted to tag along.
I'm sorry.
I want to land here.
No!
We had everything!
Beacons are beacons!
Dude, does Tembo hate you?
He hates all of us.
Oh my god.
If we don't get a beacon next game, I am accidentally
crashing my game.
Accident.
I'm also gonna accidentally crash.
how is this that's like actually so cruel because we
literally had everything and he just took it away from us we
we felt hope for like five seconds that was the most
happiness i fell in this tournament what did they do to you
what did it are you all okay man I'm so sad that was the
boba money that was the boba that was it that was it right
there I was already thinking about the small and big balls I
was ready where will my balls go now where would what the
hell oh my god how could they I'm actually hard We felt hope
That maybe this game will be different He was there, man He
was there Oh my god Oh It's okay It's okay Maybe we'll get
everything again Yeah Maybe Who are we blaming?
Who fucked up here?
I don't know who DC'd.
I think Tempo fucked up here.
Who fucked us over?
I think us actually praying on her downfall fucked us.
I think it was her that crashed again.
Was it actually her?
I'm pretty sure it was her again.
No, I don't think it was.
I don't think it was her.
I think it was her.
Karma's not real.
There's no way.
Oh, yeah.
yeah rain day said it yeah there's no way it's okay we'll
get it again what if what if we don't what if we will trust
don't put that energy out there if we don't get it again
should we just run into the first team we see yes i actually
i'm confident in our yeah i think i think honestly speaking
we're not thinkers we should just uke one we should just
grief a team and that would make me feel a little bit what
did we die that you don't you don't you don't think that you
know okay you're right we'll be positive if we have like the
balls of a controller squad and just like eight them they'll
be caught off guard and they'll like give her for like a
little bit and that's all the advantage we need oh okay okay
we got two we got two we got oh we Oh, you're on a mission.
The crash was good.
Okay, okay, okay.
You land on that bridge one.
Yeah, I'm trying to fix my chat, guys.
I'm trying to fix you guys.
Go on your little mission there in space.
I'll fix you guys.
Okay.
All right.
Who's jump master?
Okay, here you go.
We got it.
Bro, they really didn't put any ALGS rules.
I can Emo.
There's heat shields.
Am I going over there?
The...
All the way over there?
Am I going there?
I...
I don't know where you reset.
Yeah, you're going to say Space Boy.
Okay, okay.
All right.
I just got to make sure.
Yep, yep.
All right, here we go.
Oh!
We gotta make it.
I got three Phoenix.
cool hey that's good phoenixes are rare i don't want purple
scout scout goes crazy four phoenixes i don't want all of
these oh
all right this is it guys i believe in us i believe let's
see i believe I'm gonna drop two of them by the crafter.
All right, guys, this is it.
That zone?
Hey.
There's no way.
There's no way we're not gonna get top six.
Can you ping me?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have one here.
I'll ping it in a second.
Let's see.
I think I'm gonna go actually I'm gonna go nemesis I feel
like nemesis I'm better at nemesis than carbide it's like a
scouted you see one okay oh I need that dropping an extra
bat here wait scout or bolt I I meant bat did I say
something else scout scout oh see where is it I saw the
Where are the energy ammo?
I'll ping it in a second.
Does anyone want a turbo?
Uh, yeah.
Okay, there's a turbo somewhere here.
Let's go this way.
Is he playing it?
Oh yeah, I need to try and find it.
Guys, I have a panel after this.
I'm so fucking ready.
I feel like a balloon over here.
Be careful.
I'm so ready.
Do you have any Wait, get that Evo there.
Ducky.
Yeah, I'm heading over now.
Two bats in here.
Whoa.
Did you find a scout?
Yeah.
She's not gonna make it.
I just got one.
I'm trying to get water right now.
No, I lost her that light.
Let's go to our...
Oh, my God.
I can stand still here, right?
We'll go to our second floor in that building.
Nice.
We're just gonna be collecting cheese.
Okay.
Please, where's the turbo, guys?
This is kind of an awful hard zone if we, like, don't get a
spot right away so i'm heading over we're gonna be fighting
a lot all right i don't remember where the turbo is i'm
sorry let me scan this beacon you guys can start heading
towards yeah i'm heading over yep all right i'm okay i'm
okay guys i swear to god i'm okay now should no one should
be here should i get that cheese yep yep okay i'm almost
there there oh damn i only have one yeah that should stack
oh yeah i got two whoa guys i don't think we're getting a
house guys yeah we should be able to scan from either that
cliff base or cliff side or alpha base i just fucking said
two there's yeah there's a whole team in this house
all right all right we should try i'm gonna hit that alone
in uh in the zone okay so we're Maybe we can go for the
third beacon, too.
Me and a prize.
We're going to mission.
Yeah, you guys hold from this building.
Which building?
This thing.
I want a house so I can blow my nose.
The center?
I need a house.
Okay.
I can't stop moving.
I need a house so I can blow my nose.
I think we can go for the alpha.
Oh, you want to go for that one?
Please.
Yeah.
I need to blow my nose, please.
I feel like I have a loving land that way.
house i think those are the hard or the uh i did hear that
too that might have been the craft i'm not sure i'm 200 off
purple i can get cold yeah you're gonna be her you're gonna
be her we're gonna get a red too guys we got this the moment
she has gold knockdown it's over for them not for us by the
way Just in case you guys don't know, it's over for them.
I'm gonna posture up here and see what this team's doing.
I don't...
I'm gonna risk it.
I just want the bad.
They're on the other side.
They look like they're going into this building.
We have purple!
Let's go.
All right.
Where you want us...
Where are we supposed to go here?
This building.
Framing for this building.
I think they're just...
There's a gold knock here.
Going.
I don't see him.
Uh...
We should take the evo cache.
Are you going to take it?
No, I'll take it.
I'll take it.
Send an old Excel here.
Okay.
A little fridge.
All right.
I have...
I need a stock.
Holy shit.
I have a stock.
I have one gray one.
They flew over from over here.
They left, Tucker.
All right, start setting up there or just chill here in this
building.
that skinned by cliffside yeah i mean they're far to the
zones or into the beacons hold on let me put a wall for them
and all that okay well we wait
all right yeah got it yep yep
cheese over there too my team is so serious now this is the
last game we gotta be serious we're so serious is that a
crafter or a mobile rose probably the crafter
whoa i didn't even realize you guys were so far away yeah oh
there's no one here yeah no one's playing oh my god there's
a team in we could play here you know hillieries no i'm
gonna die I forgot I got my syringe.
Can you rest me, Yuge?
We have to make a position.
Oh, wait.
I'm dumb.
Yeah, I just, there's no one in here.
Do you want to heat chill?
Yeah, no one's in that building.
We should definitely go for that.
I think we can land from this.
Yeah, on the roof too.
We're good.
Yeah, yeah, let's go to this room.
I don't think there was anyone in any of, like, both
buildings.
Both buildings.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's go.
All right.
How's it?
This team did look like they were looking, though, so.
All right, come on.
Wait, let's pop a med kit together.
Yeah, well, can you drop the suckage?
Oh.
Nothing, nothing.
It's okay.
No, I don't have a med kit.
Oh yeah, I can drop you.
All right, everyone pop a med kit.
I missed it.
Oh, wait.
Can you bring it up here?
Oh.
Sorry.
Are you guys okay?
We have 20 seconds, guys.
We'll be fine.
All right.
All right, pop a med kit.
We're gonna go for either of the buildings, but probably
this one.
one mostly i'm so sorry i think i just need you to drop the
sock yeah yeah you can drop the sock it's not good oh
they're breaking the balloon we might just have to take it
oh no okay oh wait donky has a balloon wait wait i do i do i
do i do i don't show someone else someone else dropped okay
she actually dropped the balloon i dropped the balloon i
don't trust myself positioning the balloon take it take it
take it take it take it what the was that you're gonna shoot
for one of a zip zip there now go in here go in here fuck it
okay okay no one no one no one yes there's a cheese outside
we're gonna go for the next one as well i have no one's here
we get to live in the house no one's here okay i'm closing
this door next okay yep okay guys i'm gonna afk here for one
second we can't we can't don't keep okay i want to blow my
nose it's okay later oh my god We made it in!
We made it!
We made it in!
I'm going to blow my nose!
Run zone!
Dub.
It's a miracle.
I didn't even see that.
Holy shit.
Good call.
We have a house.
And I blew my nose.
I want the sock.
Oh my god.
Can I get the joke?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hold on.
Back up, Doki real quick.
Okay, buddy.
Just out of our door.
I don't know how are you?
Right here, Doki.
I'm a mess right now after blowing my nose.
No, no, no, no.
No, my discord crashed!
What just happened?
My discord crashed!
Oh, God.
Team right here now?
Guys, I'm a mess right now.
What is happening?
No.
Oh, no.
What fence is on the, on this window as well?
Scary window.
We're gonna bounce forever.
Yeah.
You should not gonna bounce forever.
Whenever we're here at Helac, we move together, you know?
Ape together strong.
Okay.
Just play together.
Are we shooting at it or on whoever's- There's one problem
after another.
Wait, there's a read-a-play over there.
Oh, all right, all right, all right.
We'll play Southwest.
Play Southwest.
I'm looking at them read-a-play.
We just gotta like- Moving this, hold on.
Where are they going?
Where do they go?
They disappeared.
I don't know.
Yeah, I don't even see anything.
They actually just disappeared.
Yeah, I was watching it.
There's a team over here.
Yeah.
Well, we're concerned.
Why is no one here?
Me too.
Hello?
How do people know all these zones?
If no one's here, then do you think zone ends on the other
side?
I mean, we have the zone knowledge.
Don't be a doomer.
Don't say that.
Oh, yeah.
We don't have redeploy.
Oh, my bad.
No, we got our zip.
Yeah, we did have a zip.
Oh, yeah, we have our zip.
You're right.
They might.
They might vault back here.
Oh, yeah.
I see that.
They just rest.
Yes, rest.
The fuck are they doing?
Yeah, it's a full team.
It's a full team.
There's definitely a different team there.
Okay.
I'm putting this wall back.
All right, we're going to find out in 14 seconds.
How is there?
You're still 14?
team squads.
Literally only one team has died this entire time.
That is crazy.
Yuris, I'm a bit scared for you, man.
Don't worry.
I got this.
We're up here.
Yeah, I'm trying to shoot him.
There's at least two or three teams.
Oh, I got shot from height.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I'm looking out in the glass right now.
It's a big cavalry race because the doors are blocked.
Oh, there's a team right here.
There's a team in the other house next to us.
I'm going to go under this door.
They weren't in here.
Open it real quick.
There's a team right here in front of me.
Hold on.
Rotating right now.
No, I'm going to move.
I killed one of the next.
Yes!
Oh.
Wait, can we get the others?
I can't.
He's in this corner right here.
Yeah, we're trying.
I hit him for 100 is knocked down.
I don't have days.
Isn't this left corner of your name?
I'm going to get him with this next one.
Okay.
I want to look on the other side just to be sure.
I'm going to...
I'm getting my rifle!
Sorry!
Sorry.
Are you okay?
Yeah, I'm so sorry.
I just... It was scary.
Um...
There...
I don't have an angle with you.
What?
I don't know.
We're not in zone.
Oh, yeah, we're not in zone.
They were right.
I think they got a knock because they put down a... They put
down a Moby Res.
This team's trying to move.
Yeah.
I think no one's in the first floor this zipping away yeah i
see it come to me come to me okay that team is watching is
there a team we're gonna fight somewhere we're getting
charged from here we have to get to the first floor of this
building there's only one team there's a guy here cracked i
knock him i knock him i think we just killed this try to
kill this team okay wait to kill this team where i don't
know where Team, you're getting short right here.
Right here!
Behind me, behind me!
He's banging all to us!
On top!
I need back!
One-feet, I'm 17, 1-17!
I'm banging all to them back!
I have a waller.
Oh, I'm a waller.
Wait, what?
Okay.
I'm raising.
I'm raising, I'm raising.
Go for the rest.
I'm watching.
Um, my alt didn't hit anybody.
My ult is fine.
You're good.
Cool.
Go full healers.
We're gonna zip to the first floor of the building that's
inside the zone.
Okay.
This guy's gonna move.
Yeah.
I'm sure he did.
You're gonna smoke, smoke the second floor and we're gonna
zip in the first floor, okay?
Where's the second floor?
Right here.
Okay.
I was like, where's the house?
Smoke that?
I'm gonna break the fence.
Just talk.
Just go, go, go, go, go, go.
Just go first floor.
We made it.
We still made it.
Build the walls.
I'm watching the circus.
All right.
I'll just walk back, locking this.
I'm watching this door.
Oh, they needed.
They needed they need it.
Yeah, they need it.
Good, you're good.
I love it.
I'm batting.
Okay, yeah, I'm covering you.
Watching stairs, watching stairs.
Okay, okay.
I'm watching our push.
Cool down.
Okay, okay, okay.
Wait.
Oh, no, it's outside the zone.
There's a guy in here.
See, there.
There's a guy like all the way over there.
He can peek from this edge.
Oh, fuck, bro.
We're in a pretty bad spot.
Wait, right there is good, but fuck me.
How are we going to...
What the fuck is going on?
Do you guys have vortex house?
I do, I do, I do, I do.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I think we can set up there now.
Where?
Right there?
You think so?
I think so.
Oh, all right.
I don't know.
I don't think I've ever played there.
Fuck it.
Trust me.
Let's go, guys.
We're gonna sit across.
All right.
We're going.
We're fucking going.
We're playing the crates.
Come here.
And we're building walls.
We're good.
I'm batting.
We're only going to focus our southeast.
It's fine.
I'm batting.
I trust you.
I can't wall for you guys.
You're good.
It's okay.
I have the bat.
It's going to be right here.
It's right here.
There's a guy.
Okay.
I see him.
Over here.
By the way.
Cracked him.
He's still in the open.
I'm going to come put a wall for you guys.
He got a shield swap.
He died.
I'm on cooldown.
Does your pack have a helmet?
There's a bat.
There's bats in the package.
Oh, come here.
Come here.
Come to us.
I'm dead.
You're good.
We live here.
That side is in, that side is in.
They're going to be chilling.
They're here.
Look at this guy.
Be careful behind us.
I'm going to termite him.
We need a new wall here.
We need a new wall here if you get one.
I'm on cooldown.
I'm termite him.
One shot, one shot, one shot.
Nice.
Oh, nice, quick.
I'm going to first.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Dub, dub, dub, dub.
big big big big big and these can these people top place oh
yeah they can they end I'm still on cooldown on walls
chapter yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna rotate rotate find me
rotate right around I'm gonna but um flush, flesh flesh
right here right here flush like one I knocked one can you
break the pylon that's a big their might okay I need a heal
I need a heal yeah they're dead They're dead.
They're dead.
Oh, no.
No, you're zipped.
No, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Come to me.
Come back.
Oh, you're good.
You're good.
You're good fucking go it'll be a clip moment watch for me
please please we're getting doki back this is work football
this is comes back up breezy i'm back i'm back come back i'm
back wait don't big that don't be that think about this this
guy can't climb this guy can climb okay he he got the
balloon though oh my god you're in a bad spot right right
filled 15 14 Really fucking bad.
Really fucking bad spot.
This guy on the left though, King Bree.
The entire team left.
Be careful, his team left.
Not another one.
Be careful this team left.
They can send us.
Yep, yep, yep, yep, yeah.
I agree, I agree.
I don't know where they are.
I don't know when this left team went.
Right.
I think they're behind you.
This last team, if- This last team.
I might- Oh, it is, it is.
He's red.
He's red armor.
43.
43, 44.
Be careful You killed one!
He's on-hide he's on-hide Get the fucking lifeline!
I'm like, he's on track, he's on track Dropping, dropping,
dropping.
They're pushing, they're pushing!
Blooming to the back!
Under us.
Yeah, nice drone, nice drone, nice drone, nice drone.
It's 2, it's 2.
Drop it!
Gloss!
Let's go!
Oh!
Oh shit, I'm wrapped up.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Let's go.
We're lazy, we're down.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
That was crazy.
You're good.
Good call on that zip.
Holy fuck.
That's fine.
That's who we beat.
Nottie's team.
We won't even beat Nottie's team.
Oh my god.
We're better.
Oh my second place.
Never first naughty.
That's what I'm saying.
Let's go.
Oh my god.
As we did it.
We hated to away.
We hated it.
Oh my god.
See you guys?
Hate wins.
Wait.
Kill leader?
Kill leader though?
Oh my god.
Oh look at us!
A 14!
We got 14.
We farmed.
Oh my god.
Guys, we're not bad people.
You got a shit talk wig.
Call him.
We're just calling him right now.
No you call him.
him oh my god we actually did it for the boba he actually we
actually won for the boba oh my god we actually we actually
did it dude doky was talking mad about you bro what she was
saying how dude she was saying how bad you were because she
couldn't win with you but she wins with us
i told her to call you but she was like no you do it tell
them tell them what i said i was like damn that's crazy tell
them we won you guys never won together once no but i think
that also just might be because we're laughing the whole
time i don't know how the we want bro i'm gonna be honest
i'll be honest dude i have no idea how the fuck all right
love you man i love you so much i'm a yeah yeah bro jeez i
could have asked for a better last game team oh that was
great that was great that was fun i can't believe we did it
guys dude that res was crazy that was crazy crazy crazy oh
we did it for the boba oh oh shay you're like top six and
kills i think you're top six i think i wait you had 15
naughty had 30 so you were not that close no but no but
first and fourth gets money the same amount so hey you got
money i got money more boba hey more but i still got the
same amount of money damn damn ggs guys the power of boba
and hate yeah yeah if you really channel it you know
remember when we it was no karma we're not bad people it's
just how the world works it's just yeah that's crazy that's
crazy to say you were just talking bad shit and you say
we're not bad people if we're bad people we would have got
punished grow up that's crazy ggs guys that was That was a
great game to end it on Good fucking game I hope to see you
guys again in the future Bye bye Bye bye bye bye bye Oh my
that was so Fun oh I can't believe we won That game that was
Actually crazy I did not bro the guy I shot died of ring Out
of all chances like I was Like bro he died of ring I was
like, I looked at it, I was like, I got a knocked and it was
last ring and I, we wore, oh, he died of a fucking ring?
Holy shit, that was actually fucking crazy.
That was so fun though.
Definitely was incredibly fun.
I'm glad, like, it took me a while to get started
socializing, but, um, and by, by time we hit game three, we
were back in our groove.
We were, I told you, Apex is so fun.
have it is more so about like who you play with and like
tournament stuff that's why i haven't been streaming much
apex because it's also more about like who i get to play
with like it's more i think like apex more about the banter
and like while you have some sometimes you get sick gameplay
footage too but the banter is so fun um yeah guys we added
more money to the tempo bank guys yeah another another
another drop of tournament money in the temple bank um all
right let me go to let me go to yihaw time oh shit oh sorry
guys sorry we were uh um we were talking about behind the
scenes stuff but we're back now i want to boost up the bgm a
little bit oh i was watching back happy i'm so happy with my
team i hope you guys had a great time watching too because
we haven't played apex in a while um um now time to cash out
it's time to cash out guys um but guys thank you all for the
super chats um i do have uh avcon to go to i have avcon to
do now so i'm sorry i can't stay for too long but thank you
all for all the super chats and all the uh memberships and
all subscribing or hanging out.
I really, really, really do appreciate it, guys.
That was a great boba ad.
Boba Tea, hire us.
Doesn't matter which company.
We literally just increased your boba tea sales by 100%.
Thank you.
Bite size.
Nice win.
Now go forward your tax forms.
Thank you.
Hey, guys.
I'm going to head off now.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me, head to bed because you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
By the way, next week, it's not going to be like super
packed to get, I don't know, maybe it will be.
I don't know.
I said I was going to take a risk.
But next week, we do have a stream with Mint.
We're playing Mana Madon.
She suggested it.
So I think that's on Tuesday or Monday.
I think it's on, is it Monday or Tuesday?
I don't remember.
July 1st.
your life versus monday is it your life yeah monday so um
but yes i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys